thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hear ye hear you man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go ahead and uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless they clean
with messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's good
[Music]
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental was an
avatar to an ebender I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he flies you
stealing mosquito you swear he ain't
something but really be Stevo you like
to collect stuff and that's cool but I
got bad news even if you really was that
dude can't ever still be the king of the
statue sister juvenile I've been cursed
with a curse to be Musical and if you
hate it we'll meet in The Crucible other
than nothing it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cause you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
lawyers day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
all right tested tested one two mic
check and all of that King will be here
don't be putting in the chat where's
King
I know people is right now in the chat
about the Tweet about the comments
put the squid out of three and I'm just
joking
anyway all right here you here watch
King's group he's crying oh yeah you
already know and we are live welcome to
the iron Lords podcast LLC and also on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 277.
it's another Glory Sunday we're back at
the round table on the Lord's date and
today we've got the series s holding
back the generation
Bayonetta three controversy continues UK
CMA asks for public opinion and Xbox
Mobile store to discuss so we're gonna
get right into it
so let's introduce the four oh we ain't
got okay
the three Horsemen he was original
gaming knives in a row while we win the
Mutiny yeah listen man we got tired
we have this new thing now before King
could come in the room he had to say
five positive things of a place
that's in the contract man like we try
to get these PlayStation game views I'm
just joking
anyway my co-host with the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his old
look he coming relax
Lord of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord addict how are we
doing sir you triggered my trap card
yeah it's doing pretty good man uh I
have been
playing some Persona 5 on uh on on Xbox
uh you know what's funny I was I was in
I was in a chat with a with smooth
yesterday and he was like well I'm about
to go live and he's like what do you
think I should name name the title I was
like well they've been on you crazy over
this Persona uh tweet I was like you
need to put something Fanboy is crazy in
that chat and he's like he's like what
so I convinced him to put what was man
what was it it was like
uh man let me let me look it real quick
oh here let me
Persona 5 Royale uh plays best only on
Xbox oh Lord here I go
it's funny though man it was funny he
got a lot of people in there yeah it's
nice to play Persona man especially on
the the platform what's funny as I I did
stream it on uh on this on the IOP
Channel and there was people in the chat
I've never seen so there's people
looking up streams on you on YouTube for
persona
because there was people in there I have
never seen in the chat ever that's
interesting yeah man and I you know I
think the streamy thing's getting bigger
on YouTube I think they're pushing it
more uh because there was people going
on that I looked
render the chats the king is late
because he is currently being held back
by series as Hardware
hilarious continue but it was it was
nice man it's nice that Persona so I
said I've said persona 5's on the
platform we just got to see what Persona
6 shows so yeah it's gonna be a big deal
it'll be a big deal whether or not it
happens we shall see anything else
you've been playing sir
a Persona 5 mainly uh you know people
kept asking me did I finish scoring no I
did not finish school and I think
I think I dropped it the moment the show
that streaming oh damn it was old
no more dripping fat lie for him
I had like a little like
just chatting session at the end of the
straight uh the scoring uh Stream So I
dropped a Deering the string so he said
look it's
we didn't really talk about it last week
I know that we were we said we were
going to mention it but we didn't really
look scorn has amazing atmosphere and I
think that if it would have been done
correctly it could have been something
special like it's like I've said a
couple times
scoring has some of the best atmosphere
I've ever seen in the game like they
really get you immersed in this world's
creepy they have a lot of like weird
noises and you put your fingers in
places it didn't look like it belongs
a lot of squelching noises
you know with all that going it's I feel
like the game does really well in doing
that but people sit there and say addict
you know the reason they don't do the
the story thing they want you to they
want you to find the story I'm not doing
their job and it's their job to sell me
a story it's not my job to find the
story I feel that and it's like I I use
this analogy last week it's like
equivalent to plain Dead Space because I
honestly feel like if they would have
actually built scorn like around the
immersive and not really like because I
think the game's too much like shock
value at this point
oh the the atmosphere of the game as
opposed to executing like a really
thought out story yeah so it I feel like
if they would have like the foundation
of school would have been the atmosphere
and the immersion and the lore and the
building that they're doing and they
build everything around it it would be
just as good as something like that
space okay uh but the problem is it's
like dead space does that and it also
has an enticing story that is told well
right like it's equivalent it's like I
said this last week it's equivalent at
the beginning of Dead Space for those of
you that's played it you go to the ship
because your girlfriend's missing yeah
she she sent you like this video saying
stuff's going wrong you go there to find
out what happened with these marines
it's equivalent to being dropped off at
that ship with no Marine conversation
your girlfriend hasn't said anything you
just oh we're here we're here like
there's no contacts like that I got you
yeah for what I hear Too is it's like
maybe this sets up someone said score
kid my hair loss oh they Wildlife
somebody says God is moist
very moist so basically but do you think
like the foundation is there for like a
good sequel do you think that this is
their first game too
so I think it's a it's one hell of a
first game like but as far as they need
people in there to write a a story they
need people in there to they got such a
unique world and there's no lore to it
really okay and then people are like
well addicts it's what you find no I
didn't like it in bloodborne I didn't
like in Eldon ring I want the story told
to me through the narrative I don't want
to go look up runes go to another
website look you know what annoys me
there's people here we go that make a
living oh telling lore on from software
games on YouTube when you have to leave
the at the PlayStation and Xbox to bring
up YouTube to find out who you just
killed
is that intrinsically in the game of
souls fans you you got to be careful
that's the song no it's just people with
magnifying glasses make fantastic videos
to explain it better than from software
explains
[Music]
for the single player selfish experience
and also the sastra Davis the Lord of
clarity and Lord patriarch of the iron
bank my man Lord Sovereign how are we
doing sir I'm all right do a little bit
better uh still hacking up along every
now and again but still you know I'm
getting there I'm getting there but uh
all right I'm doing good uh glad to be
back uh what are we doing what are we
doing I have to think about what I'm
doing because I'm not doing much
which is breaking my heart because I
love Plankton that say I love that I
love that game so I was very excited
when they got announced and uh I'm
hearing great things so I'm I'm excited
to play it when I can
um I have Gotham Knights installed we'll
see we'll see if you spent money on golf
tonight of course that's pretty much
listen I'm not I'm not about I'm not
gonna sit here and berate a game without
playing it myself
oh you see here's the difference I have
no problem back talking to gay man
playing no problem whatsoever I'm all
about the second hand information
[Laughter]
I mean I guess I'm a Batman dude so I I
have to see what this looks like Plus
I was always that dude that did not
understand
the backlash that Origins got like
Origins was a very good game and it just
got you know thrown on the bus actually
I was debating this last yeah last night
with uh with Kai I totally forgotten
shout out to him I forgot that it
Origins launched poorly like in terms of
uh technical issues like it was it was
really broke there's a lot of the PC
though I didn't really have too many
people issues with that well he actually
pulled the receipts he pulled the
receipts about game breaking bugs
if you had a bad time or experience he's
gonna have the Articles and the receipts
ready to go he pulled the receipts I'm
thinking about nights nights well no it
was both it was across the board it was
just bad it wasn't as bad as it was
really bad on PC and not console well so
both of them were bad knights was the
one that was horrible like unplayable
and Origins was just buggy and then on
the console side that coupled with the
console side of it made the launch out
of you know it wasn't what it should
have been in addition to oh this isn't
Rock Steady this is some other team and
all of that together made it so that
that game just got a bad rep and I never
quite understood it usually when people
get over the technical stuff you see the
game for what it is but it kind of
always stuck like hey it's not as good
as the other ones I you know I beg to
differ I think it's kind of on par but
whatever but I was hoping for w Montreal
to use this opportunity to
take the reins of this type of Batman
game you already know the rockstead he's
doing something different right with
Suicide Squad take the ring take the
learnings from all the Arkham games your
own game and make the next iteration of
that type of game and it feels like they
haven't done that and that's
disappointing I'll see for myself when I
actually play it okay
um what else I saw Black Adam yesterday
right
I apologize we'll watch it I was under
the ropes I enjoyed it another one it's
getting hate like it's the worst thing
ever positive negative I'm hearing the
disparity between the critical reviews
versus I'll be like the okay like the
creators review like the critics versus
the peoples is such a disparity and I'm
seeing that the people like yo what are
you talking about critics yeah this is
fire I feel like that happens a lot
because critics always review it in the
genre it is and people tend to to watch
a movie based on the merits of that
movie and not well look what Marvel's
doing over there and I felt I feel like
when a Critic watches something then
they're comparing it to their Brethren
like people in that genre yeah but but
even then it's still weird because I
look at it my my gripes with the movie
are is that I felt it could have been 20
maybe even 30 minutes longer really to
give me more Exposition about like um no
spoilers here but like the movie starts
out with like a narrator telling you the
back story of of how teth Adam Black
Adam came to be right so this isn't like
an Origins it is business Powers well it
they do it very quickly at the start of
the movie okay right now they should be
yeah I don't like that man when you're
introducing him like that when you're
introducing him for the first time if oh
I mean I guess since he's never had his
own movie but if I had one more if I see
one more Spider-Man origin I'll pull my
hair out yeah but how many times have
they done the Spider-Man origin yeah he
needs I I would have liked to because
they did it right but they did it with
an a narrator and they kind of sped
through it right rather than give me 20
minutes with this character and show me
exactly exactly what happens and why
it's important right same thing with the
Justice Society right you've seen the
commercials with Hawkman or whatever if
they would have given me a little more
Exposition with them like before they
they they they they meet up with Black
Adam whatever happens like show me why
they are the team that they are show me
why those relationships are the way that
they are
it would have hit a little bit better
for me but even better but in terms of
the action it was there it just felt
rushed it felt like they were trying to
rush through everything but in terms of
the acting the little side comedic stuff
uh the rock sort of stoicism mixed in
with sarcasm and and and and and and and
sort of uh like seriousness and a little
bit of Rock comedy but not not what
you'd expect everything worked for me it
just it just flew too fast and I wasn't
a big fan of the villain per se but
apart from that like when I started
seeing fives and stuff like what's the
worst thing ever yeah have y'all seen
Fantastic Four
Rise of the Silver surface no not that
one I'm talking about these photos yeah
that was bad
um yeah so I don't understand that the
hate from the critic critic side of it I
enjoyed it I wish hopefully there's
maybe a director's cut with a little
more in it later on but I liked it I
thought it was good no doubt No Doubt
and you already know the Incredible Hulk
should be on his way so relax but you
still got me and then he's coming
this should know me you know what I'm
saying back fresh off that Ireland trip
little jet lagged y'all a little little
time zone job I'm hurting I'm hurting
man I can't even get my own intro right
like
let me first off I gotta I gotta come
out for coming at some people real quick
let's get a chance to play by um my
series that's for like majority of these
flights United Airlines we got to talk
no no Outlets we got to talk about your
outlet situation first of all to run
this run the um the series that you need
about um 100 Watts or the outlet
and I checked it says 100 Watts you know
what I'm saying everything looked fine
plug it in I got the up screen got the
joint
won't power up so I'm like all right so
I've been forced to steam that then when
I got to um the hotel the um the
Internet situation really wasn't the
greatest so we couldn't do no expenses
so I'm like you know what
fine but I had one time before this I
did a flight like more than six hours or
so at American Airlines an American
like y'all plugged in the series that
little man rocking playing all my games
doing what I got to do so yeah man
United Airlines yo if you don't get this
you don't get your outlet situation
together I'm literally not and I I like
United that's the crazy like I usually
don't have too many issues so it's like
now I'm like not fam I can't be doing
six plus hours and it ain't no no so you
plugged in it was just nothing yo it
acknowledges that power is it because
usually there's a green light all right
um these plugs as soon as you plug it in
the green light go off as if I've
exceeded so basically what they said
they have not put the wattage to the max
of the 100 that it's allotted it's right
it's just that's the max that it's
allowed in yeah so it doesn't accept
that yeah so anyway so that's been that
but anyway as far as being all as far as
I'm shout out to the father doing shout
out for Maddie shout out to Ben Smith
holding me down did the father Duke was
lit and shout out to um I believe um
Hogue who pulled up for ultimate they
did a good one so shout out to Maddie
I'll be back mad if we get right back in
the mix yeah they killed it they said
Ben said that you were in Ireland
infecting his people with the Zuck juice
they saying I'm low all right hold on
one second let me turn my joint up a
little bit they said they're saying Cog
is low hold on do that a little bit get
my level up a little bit but um yeah so
you know that and then shout out to
um my people shout out to ebonta shout
out to Travis holding me down you know
what I'm saying they had uh did the all
black word a lot of stuff going on
Festival loss I gotta catch up see
what's going on there but as far as me
being that I've been steam deck
exclusive
I've been playing a particular game
finally now that it came over to
um PC game pass that's trending that's
straight oh oh okay standing
definitely I need you to come to the
front of the congregation we gotta talk
we gotta talk to Australia all right
here's the thing so I'll remember
the thing about this game first of all
let's let's get to it it's a beautiful
game right graphically is is hashtag
just one energy the cinematics are
gorgeous you know Norman Reedus you know
they got your man groom that's Del Toro
you know it it's a beautiful looking
game I will not discount that you know
I'm saying steam that get your frame
rate together though steam that get your
frame rate together you'll be
fluctuating from 30 then 60 it's all
over the place so you but you were you
were clouding it right Cloud no no I
steamed that I steamed that once I could
I play Cloud initially and I was fine
but then when I got on the flight I
can't do Cloud so you you have the
downloaded version right all right cool
so all right desperate engine fire care
front you know cinematics okay I'm
getting into it dog we're okay what's
going on
and it reminded me of if this wasn't
anybody name
hideo Kojima
could they get away with this
could they get away and the reason why I
say this is some of the story to me so
far and I'm like maybe four or five
chapters in
it's so nonsensical to me like it's so
ridiculous to me it's you know we got to
get the packages and we got to save the
world we gotta you're a glorified FedEx
agent that's what it is you're literally
it's the gameplay Loop is your oh on the
right side you got a bag you got four
things on your back make sure you even
when you walk in and balance yourself
hold your chest together so you don't
fall over like I'm literally in one
biome
going through and delivering picking up
random packages on the ground then the
thing is it he had the moment again
where
again I love his games he he does think
out the box which is part of his genius
but the part that gets me is remember
Metal Gear Solid 2 where he lost me
right that the game that was a game
where Raiden was introduced I remember
we were like very upset I wasn't even
really upset with Ray was introduced
where he lost me is the fake deepness
it's the fake deepness bro it's basic
concepts
it's literally deliver packages the
world got this you know and the BB with
the BT and I'm like what is this baby
thing like what what is the we gotta
connect to babies in the jar why does it
do they have to be named die hard man
then why he got a mask in the room with
the president like what score like it
it's just it's weird for the same thing
deepness for no reason like that that
it's just you got it yeah that's BG's
favorite phrase so much fake deepness
this is again is it Garb now here's the
thing it's not whack don't get me wrong
like
I'm gonna find myself [ __ ] too
positive I still haven't found myself
not wanting to play and see where it
goes I will admit that there is
something to the loop that is making me
still like all right but there's just
certain parts where I start to get into
it
and then the story it it get it it's the
Lolly moments and they start talking
about all this extra stuff and I'm like
bro it's not that deep just tell me what
to do and that's it and and that's the
part that gets me and it's a shame
because
graphic the game's beautiful you know
what I'm saying and maybe as it goes on
deeper the fake deep this gets unraveled
and you really get to it but right now
but what happens is this the fake
deepness gets unraveled and you realize
how shallow that bridge really is and
it's like really bro like he
like they
they got yo you rated like they they
rate your deliveries they'd be like yo
yo you you did your thing on that one
you didn't drop
it's like they're acting like they have
a commission and an apocalypse raiding
your like they should be happy they're
just getting ate like they gotta rate it
the funnest one I will say is you know
constructing little watchtowers and
stuff in the field you get the little I
understand this now I will say this
him with Cloud could be scary right yeah
because no no you're right I see how
other players left their stuff in the
world they create little bridges for you
and stuff like that so Kojima with Cloud
Tech could be a beautiful thing like he
because they literally got Facebook
systems in their Integrations and things
like that and I'm curious to see what he
does with it but um yeah I would say the
stealth was kind of cool you got the
little thing and you got the little rope
you know said you get behind and choke
them up you know what I'm saying kind of
thing but it's literally it's it's FedEx
versus DHL there's other reporters
trying to stop you from delivering and
I'm like this is literally UPS versus
FedEx beef in the game
post-apocalyptic feel so look shout out
to him
I know a whole a lot of people swear by
this game it's just it's just luck man
it's just a little fake beat for me and
if if they just cut around all that
other extra stuff
we might as well give them the bad news
right now
check your check your messages oh man
what's going on it's called out I owe
the call out okay okay just tell me
because it's cool yeah
it's not the king I guess he can't make
it he's doing a whole bunch of stuff he
cannot make it no that's cool shout out
to the kid we got things going on you
know she got it it never calls out you
never call out so you know you're not
doing so hopefully he said cancel the
pocket
yeah let's get these super chats out of
the way we're starting off with flame
remember to for two years two dollars
for chat is this the iron Lords podcast
yes it is flame thank you very much
yeah we got done on Taco two dollars it
wasn't cool they finally overthrew the
king
too much love for kids
they would get hard to find remember for
18 months Lord bronze thank you sir
assalamu alaikum my brothers Cog let's
get our Super Bowl tickets now nine is
winning it all oh listen I'm excited I'm
excited I mean I just gotta see because
as much as I love the move he does get
hurt a lot so hmm
wavy coaster let's put the crest in the
chat for wavy coaster all right thank
you sir appreciate that yeah we have
that LeBron Donald Taco five dollars to
protect five days until Game of the Year
big controversy and not being there the
three is swooping the rest of the year
including Ragnarok very confident is
down the top very costly very confident
we got flamed once again two um two
years not for two years two dollars
Super Chat Cog they know this series s
holds back the plane speaking of which
look who joins us
we got wavy kosher once again remember
for two months Lord bronze shout out to
the Lords and the realm love the
chemistry between y'all it's uncanny
Sundays are just better with IOP thank
you sir we appreciate that I appreciate
no doubt slow
then we got uh put the crust in the chat
for pecan Fusion shout out to you sir
appreciate that no the absolutely we
have the homie Hardy Shani five dollars
to protect what the king and those other
dildos that you're in the way you're in
the way Cog your face is in the way wait
the king and those other dudes podcast
won't have King jokes salute to the
remaining Lords thank you we appreciate
the support the other dudes appreciate
it all the dudes appreciate you man
thanks for showing it up
uh let's see what else we got I said
we're cut we're covered all right no
doubt flame what's going on brother can
you hear me Mike check you build it on
Zoom let's make sure you good uh can you
hear me there you go yeah my name is in
the building
my time no waiting for you to pounce on
your opportunity where's King what have
you done with King flame
don't look at me
just a little bit and we'll be good to
go so uh let's get into this poll last
response also ending the people have
spoken to the question with the latest
controversy regarding bayonet
bayonetta's voice actors wages and calls
for a boycott where do you stand in
relation to buying Bayonetta three the
winner of the three-way IOP poll at 46
percent of the vote was the messy Lords
I don't care we need to all stand
against the real issue plaking in the
street these 30 frames per second Next
Generation games coming in at second
place at 38 of the vote was Gamers
should not feel socially pressured to
penalize the remaining members of the
dev team and still enjoy the game group
okay in last place at 14 of the vote was
Gamers need to take a unified stand
against unfair wages given to
underappreciated talents in the games
industry Lloyd addict how do your
thoughts the people went the other way
with this they talking about another
subject other than the bandana one but
uh what's your thoughts on this man and
I'm going to save a lot of my thoughts
for the actual topic
[Laughter]
I do want to say something real quick
it's funny that I was I was reading
comments of last week's show and
people's like it was like it was too
short and I'm like okay so we do two and
a half hours which is what people
normally which is above what normal
podcasts normally do and that's too
short like excuse me I'm sorry we got
y'all spoiled I'm sorry but that's just
the case it is what it is people want
more people want more and I appreciate
that I appreciate it but yeah I mean
when you have the biggest podcast in the
world doing an hour and it they do an
hour and they're like oh we're running
late time to go
[Laughter]
so let's get into this y'all a lot to
discuss this has been a hot one and I
believe Lord solved this is you right
you are up series that's what's going on
here potatoes I'm hearing generation
talk what's happening
so all of this conversation stem from
the uh
when WB Montreal came out and said that
uh Gotham Knights would not run at
higher than 30 frames per second on
consoles uh and the reason for that was
that for them the co-op that they built
into the game was just untethered
essentially allowed two players I don't
know if anything beyond the two players
to play in the same world together but
not be remotely even Tethered to one
another meaning they can be doing
distinct different things in different
parts of the world and
um
for that reason they could not hit a 60
FP or Beyond 30 FPS on consoles
um
the conversation on Twitter went where
everyone expected it to go and then a
Dev that works at Rocksteady interjected
uh with his sort of take on why this is
happening and but one of the things that
he said really start kind of an S storm
on Twitter indicating and he had and
he's spoken to this effect in the past
as well indicating that the series s is
the reason why these Baseline sort of
cuts have to be made to gain little man
it is to blame oh no
and that started like I said an f-storm
on Twitter uh debating whether that is
actually the truth or it's just whatever
other developmental things that cause
the game not to be able to run at that
you know or decisions that were made
during the development of the game which
you know prevented from hitting that 60
FPS which frankly since we've started
this generation
they have a custom Gamers two Gamers the
console Gamers who were accustomed to 30
FPS sometimes sub 30 FPS in the past are
now accustomed to at least having the
option to go lower resolution in favor
of performance or higher resolution in
favor of a lot dirty right most games
now give us at least that option and a
lot of people after seeing playing games
at 60 FPS will tell you that that
smoothness when you go back to 30. 30
even looks a smooth 30 looks choppy
initially after coming back from 60. so
you know you just the custom Gamers to
those options period so the fact that
this was not the case with this game in
a game that many people just looking at
it outwardly say it doesn't look like
it's anything special graphic or
anything like that why is it doing this
so this was the whole big thing and then
obviously the conversation around the
series s has gone all different places
where some people are agreeing some
people are saying no that it's BS that's
PS argument because of the scalability
of inherent to game making
so what do you guys think because I know
where I stand on this I I I'll go last
okay you're aching this bad way this is
this is a hot one this one is breaking
up the internet you know what I mean
everybody got something to say let's
start with flame launch gaming.net oh
you know joining the building like what
are your thoughts are you seeing
developers like so I was talking about
um allegedly saying that the series s
holding the generation back allegedly
yeah uh but we can as my audio good now
yeah you're good you go okay good uh
well first of all that uh one developer
he I don't I don't want to like write
off his work because he's literally just
a character artist he doesn't really
work in level design or engineering so
it's really hard to take him as where he
might hear stuff from other developers
but I don't I don't want to lend a lot
of credits to that it's probably just
you know just objection hearsay that
kind of stuff
um
I don't buy it for a minute because
spicy flame okay it's just okay they
have a whole another Co-op thing right
okay that's fine but think about the
people that are only going to play this
Co-op you're telling me that people who
are playing alone have to
suffer because of evidence of the co-op
experience that they can't play with
that doesn't make any sense whatsoever
and two this game was a PlayStation 4
and Xbox One title like until May this
year they dropped that support I think
you guys might have talked about it but
it's like
this game was supposed to run on
consoles that were much worse than the
Xbox series s so it really so again I'm
just not buying any of this
and let's just cover this with the fact
that uh
this one
his accounts deleted as well as a couple
of other developers what if he was Silas
what if he's telling the true flame what
if they not let him speak this
potatoes in the Rock Steady Studio that
just runs around with a knife I got you
um yeah no it's just like I get it if
you're insulting you know probably that
you're technically working on the
company will shut you up at the same
time it's like
this guy has the kind of virtual that
you would see from the kind of people
that we would have either muted or
blocked basically he is he I have an
entire article about Gotham Knights
where I have like four different
screenshots of what he said
yeah it's it's not professional
whatsoever so it's really hard to take
that kind of personality
he he gives me the vibe and you know I
don't know the dude individually I don't
even know what his name is but when I
was reading screenshots of what he was
saying he gives me the vibe it's like a
PlayStation fan will got a job
what are we doing well we do careful
yeah and I'm not saying that carefully
he wait no I don't like being careful
he's the one that's better not me
you implying though
being an influencer on the internet man
I can tell you right now a developer uh
X I don't know
um
he can't be used against you uh in the
court of Twitter uh-huh
at the same time it's like the
PlayStation 4 and Xbox One we're gonna
run this that's gonna run this game at
30 frames anyway so it feels like they
just ported the current gen versions and
just did like a Xbox One X patch or PS4
Pro patch for
the you know the modern engine cost was
just called it a day because I don't
think this game is getting delayed any
further and I think we know that it got
delayed a year as well so it's kind of
just
if it was designed to run on worse
Hardware than the Xbox series s there is
actually no credibility to the
complaints on the Xbox because it's
pulling anything back
now Plateau is a different story
whatever comes to the next gen because
I've seen stuff in that game that's
actually kind of very technically
impressive to somebody that doesn't even
know game design but yeah again that's
another topic but um go ahead addict
nothing nothing addict man what you
think Man series as holding the
generation back little man in question
going on well I don't
I don't think this dude meant like
anything extremely negative I do think
he was speaking out of pocket on the way
he was handling
this conversation in general didn't
really seem too professional considering
where he works but it's just like look
you know you look at this I I did reach
out to some developers about this whole
scenario what I'm doing I'm gonna read
what they told me oh we get some
development okay
oh but the thing is
I got I got to beep out some things in
it because it will allude to where this
individual works okay
what are the streets talk we talking to
the devs what are the streets saying
so keep in mind this is someone that
works on all the platforms this isn't uh
this is an art director okay oh yeah
yeah
you had to do that so okay again quote
unquote this online co-op is hard
untethered crop is even harder much much
harder now I don't know how the game was
built or how the engine code is exactly
handling things but I bet having to sync
all that data for the AI game objectives
objective transformed uh information
Etc will cause a huge toll does that
mean all systems need to be locked at
the same frame rate so that everything
has the same tick and remain in sync
that's one way of doing it Blake used to
do this
with something of uh with uh with
thinking about that the one thing there
was in the series s does come into play
is less memory which would make it much
harder to keep all that information in
sync however there is PC ports and all
variable frame rate across machines and
they will be Co-op the main takeaway is
that devs are describing is insanely
complicated it has come with drawbacks
which is uh What uh whenever is the
right choice or not is a whole different
decision but I'm sure they had to make
some tough trade-offs Blake try to do
untethered cop and ran into a ton of
issues which is why there is a radius ah
okay so basically go ahead I'm sorry
I'll let you finish I'll let you finish
it seems like
I you know I talked to a few people it
does seem like I talked to a bunch of
people it does feel like there are some
developers that don't particularly like
working with the series s but it seemed
like more of a more work not necessarily
like it limits them what they can do
uh but it seemed like the majority of
the reasons this game was pushed for 60
uh for 30 frames is because of the
untethering and if you think about it
there's not many co-op games that's
that's untethered like if you really sit
down and think about it there is not
many co-op games that's untethered even
even on certain
like oh you know State of Decay they
said they couldn't get it to work on
tethered I know the Far Cry games for
the most part they're not untethered
like they're
untethering seems like it's very very
complicated well it's funny you said
that because I remember didn't we have
um one of the
what is it Undead Labs back in the day
right where yeah we had we were talking
about a state of decay too and the thing
at the time was that radius right where
all four players could not stayed with
it they had to stay within the
constraints of of a radius kind of thing
so it's not Halo infinite people are in
the chapter saying I peeped out hey
Johnny Johnny
it's coming from
there is truth to that there is true to
that and stuff like that but anyway I'll
let you finish it through it before I go
I think that
there are limitations to what can
actually be done but I don't think it's
the limitations that you guys think I
think for the most part
you know if it was just the Xbox series
s and X I would say 100 the S is holding
the X back 100 the S is holding costs
back in general but
most of these games are coming out for
PC right and they they go back all the
way to the 20 series cards
it's just like to me
I don't see how it affects games that's
already being in development so
it's just it's kind of crazy to me that
I just don't understand why this
individual decided to speak his concerns
in that way like he's got he's bold like
he's bold he was outside with it look at
the end of the day and but then you can
look at it like some of these
recommended it's specs now for these
newer games they're in they're intense I
don't know for sure next Generation
games like 30 series 30 70 is a
recommended spec like that that's a lot
so you know maybe maybe there is some
truthful with the man saying I'm not a
I'm not a developer by any means I can
only go to people you know if tomorrow I
took over uh
so some type of Auto Engineering Company
I ain't going to be on the on the line
making parts for for a car do you have
to hire someone else to do it look it's
this is a Highway man this is a highway
I know Sean's been booking this thing so
I jump in you know I want to be
extremely respectful
and y'all know I'm very Pro Dev like I'm
always about the developer I always lean
towards development of most arguments
you know what I mean and the other thing
is I'm a techie so I've always I get the
mindset of like yo I want the most power
available to create and do what I want
to do right I understand that mindset
that so I can empathize with developer
yo they got the more powerful X and
whatever they want to go balls to the
wall or you know next Generation
features or whatever I get that aspect
the part that I struggled which seems
weird to me is that we've been in a
multi-configuration
multi-sku kind of development process
for some time now like this is not new
like we've had PS4 PS4 Pro we had Xbox
One S and Xbox One X right and now
reporting to PC more than ever news
flash like I have a 1070 in my in my
right here there's a Texas Avenue going
on now my CPU is lit my memory is okay
right but basically what I'm trying to
say is whenever the Next Generation game
comes out they gotta account on PC for
my SKU that it can run on a 1070 which
is lower than you know I'm saying the
series that so all I'm trying to say is
that
at the end of the day generally the
lowest common denominator is is always
what it started for as far as game depth
right from a PC configuration usually
start with the lowest common denominator
and then you spec up right now from what
I hear with the Xbox One X Dev kits when
they get it there's like a series that's
mode there is no series that's advocate
for my understanding there's a series s
mode and then that puts it in the mode
where it would have that spec config now
I want to be clear
the thing that is different is the
memory the CPU and the GPU from the exit
s is virtually the same the issues
remember I'm not going to Discount
having less memory it's not being an
issue I'm not going to be disrespectful
all I'm saying is that if there if if
there's third party releases that are on
Xbox One base if they're on PC bass and
let's not act like the switch is not out
here y'all the switch is still out here
getting ports which here's the problem
people have to understand that this the
series s
is also arguably their most successful
console right now if you look overseas
if you look at Japan that's not going
away so just like attic I said you know
what let me not speculate let me go talk
to the people
let me go to talk to the devs that's
actually who gonna remain anonymous for
the sake of this you're gonna say but
let me go talk to the people and they
like cobbler
we ain't gonna be disrespectful
but this is way overblown and I'm like
really I'm trying to defend the comments
I'm like but really people say yo this
joint is a potato yo yo this this
holding back to death like they like bro
this has been going on for years like
with pre-series s there's always the
lowest common denominator that you have
to expect for that has not changed you
know what I'm saying I remember when
people were talking about the um the
cell process of a PS3 was a problem now
we're not going to say this about
challenges right but there's always
going to be spec even if you look at the
PS5
remember the PS5 SSD so it's technically
a different configuration yeah it's
definitely a supposedly a higher SSD
configuration okay that is that is more
integrally integrally integrated into
how that machine runs right yeah and
it's not just an SSD you kind of throw
supposedly just slap in there it's very
integral to how the games run so you
have to account for that when you so
that's another skew it's another skew so
again why the series s is being single
without is laughable to me because at
the end of the day we've we've existed
in a first world man this is a not only
is it we've always existed with multiple
skus this generation is the most
cross-generation cross-plat of course
Generation generation we've ever seen
where we're still having games that are
on is it Ragnarok still or whatever
again and and Herman holster said that
that may be extended even more right
Halo infinite still could be playing on
a business it's just not the Spider-Man
2
but look it's just like we we got to
remember and here's the other things
what this is what I think is going on
again I spoke to a lot of people and now
yes there are some devs that for the
like to say this to the people I suppose
they are a studio so to speak that
wasn't a fan
of dealing with the S as much I will say
that right but when I speak to the rest
and I'm like yo what about said Studio
that's like yo they like [ __ ] not almost
like not that it's cap but it's like bro
that's part of game development you have
to adjust you have to work there's
always going to be something that you
may have to put a little more time into
to get the set effect and you know how I
know that's true Remember When
cyberpunk came out and there was no 60
frames per second mode it's like it
couldn't be done what series s remember
when die and light came out no 60 frames
per second mode couldn't be done sir was
just hold it back now months later if
it's impossible how are they able to do
it so to me it's tooling learning the
hardware and doing things better and I
get it as devs you want more and I'm
never going to be disrespectful to the
day shout out to the cops was going by
they very they're coming for some deaths
at the end of the day at the end of the
day you know it's it's just a different
skew and I get it no everybody wants max
power and Max thing from the jump and no
one wants to now the best argument I
think against it
is if you want to talk about next
Generation game design as a whole like
you want to talk about next the game the
limitations of game designs but you
can't if that's the case you still can't
sing about the series s because you're
now porting to PC more than ever these
games are coming to PC more than ever
they have to account for everybody's
potato that is not as serious as it is
Noah's competent last thing I'll say and
I'll move on is that um
I'm looking at what is it Modern Warfare
2 right now right
series that's 1440p 60 frames per second
Forza Horizon 5. gears five Hive Busters
I play series that's almost exclusively
now because I travel so much so I see
the console for what it what it could do
Microsoft flight simulator is running on
a series s right so again it's about
taking the time and the fact that they
don't have the 4K
threshold that they have to meet you
could actually do some compensation
there and the other thing I thought was
quite interesting did y'all see the um
the comparison when they had I believe
it was um gospel nights series ass
Xbox one oh PS5 and Xbox series X and
the series s is holding the 30 frames
per second because they don't have the
4K requirements yeah exactly just so
again I'm gonna be respectful I get it
game development you know what I'm
saying it's hard work but we got to be
clear like this is nothing new so it's
all this isolating one particular thing
I'm not necessarily buying it and for
the people who I speak to who are actual
Developers for multiple Studios they're
not buying it so that's just that's what
the streets are talking about so I'll
let you finish I mean you guys said
everything you guys didn't really did
your research on this I appreciate that
what you guys really did say everything
it's it's the argument shout out shout
out and rest in peace the Optimus code
yes this is I wish I was here for this
yeah
um you know it was the idea of of the
ubiquity of game design across all these
platforms right and the idea of how
design is marred by the fact that you
have to hit all these different skus and
that I that part I agree with right but
but the the thing I always disagree with
code on was that the the fact that
design is affected is something that is
intrinsic to games it's always going to
be the case because if you're designing
across all of these all of these
platforms you have to think before you
even start designing what limitations
there are right and what can't what I
can and cannot do and that's just a fact
about it right unless you're only
focused on one console one SKU and you
can you can push that to the Limit this
is a consideration that is intrinsic to
game design period and let me interrupt
you with yourself here's the other thing
we're forgetting the business part
because we can sit here from a
technological standpoint and say if
these consoles are holding back let's
put these particular screws right but if
the most popular console is Switched in
series s guess what's gonna happen you
gonna learn how to develop foreign
console and the PlayStation 4 base for
PlayStation 4 Pro is the most powerful
console so guess what you're gonna have
to learn to do it exactly we have to do
that in the program for and guess what
consumers guess what you're gonna have
to eat exactly and if you don't want to
eat that I have a console for you it's
called the 40 90. go go get that you'll
get that console
good thing I'm sorry that's good no no
you're absolutely right and this is the
thing and what we don't think about when
we don't think about when we make these
comments and talk about this is the fact
of how and we've talked about this in
the past
business and art are intrinsically a
pushed together in the gaming space in a
way that doesn't happen anywhere else
right and the fact of the matter is that
because the art has begotten so
expensive to make because of the quality
that we expect as Gamers right the
business aspect of it is going to it's
going to inherently affect it even more
because it's a balance that has to be
reached by how much money and resources
we spend on making this the very best it
can be or do we spend it on marketing it
across x amount of platforms and
maximize our sales so that we can
gradually continue to make more higher
higher quality products right it is
there it is a business consideration
that I don't like I don't like the fact
that it's a reality but it is a reality
it is so when you look at this and you
look at you know you see Dev saying
quietly oh many devs are saying that
this is an albatross I want receipts
right I don't you say you have the you
have the you have the the the now like I
said Gall but you you have the the
stones to say it come out and and be
like I said this because of this reason
and the fact of the matter is that it is
just another skill that you have to
develop exactly and that's what it is
maybe you don't want to take the time to
do it and all the studios are not
created equal either exactly I'm a
talent level let's begin another thing
let's be clear there are a teams there
are B Teams hello and sometimes the B
Teams are sort of relegated to making
ports for others right or or not even B
Teams but teams that you bring in on
contractually support things that
happens as well so
is it is it an easy thing to do I don't
absolutely I have no nothing about it
and I and I know that it's not an easy
thing to do but the fact of the matter
is that this creating skus across a
number of different platforms is
intrinsic to how games are made always
period period period And even and even
the companies that have been used to
doing it on only one platform right look
at PlayStation now they have to start
expanding and looking at the PC platform
and then all of a sudden when you look
at the PC platform it's not it's not
like they decided to be like hey we're
gonna make things for Xbox now right
that's one SKU no you went to the
platform that has a range of skus that
you not have to consider when you make
these ports so
pretty much everybody's in the same boat
now where when you make a game and you
want it to be on as many platforms and
be as accessible as possible the fact of
the matter is yeah all of these
considerations have to be made and the
series s is just another consideration
to put it out there as this Albatross
that is holding back everything
messing up the Jazz and the thing about
it is and the crazy thing about it is
that there are PC
up there and PC players with the
expectations
bro
I have a laptop with a 1060 in it and
when you look the 1060 is the most
popular Jeep you also talk to them yes I
don't think you can really use those
those surveys a whole lot because a lot
of these PC Gamers they're they're
playing fortnite OverWatch they're
playing very low demanding games that
don't need these higher Graphics but
they do use it as the metric isn't like
one of the most popular games on Steam
Counter-Strike that I mean I could
probably but that doesn't happen that
doesn't that doesn't eliminate the fact
diminish the fact that what they're
playing it on exists it is the majority
and it's the majority
is when the majority of cons of PC
people are are playing this selective
games to the left and they're not really
playing these selected games to the
right obviously said when you have more
people playing this type of game you're
going to see more of the the cards that
run these type of games and if you can
get away with running a 1080 during the
early 20 series card and the majority of
the gamers are playing those games they
have no reason to upgrade that's why I
get what you're saying you see the
the minimum or the recommended specs for
a lot of these newer games is way higher
until my point you're absolutely right
and to my point I give it back to you
song I still got to get flame but to my
point that's where the business comes in
right because the business is going to
say well look they all on 1060. you know
what I'm saying or over here like it
comes down to you cater towards where
the people most likely are right now to
your point yes next Generation games
when you look at minimum spec oh boy
it's getting higher oh boy some of these
minimum requirements are are much higher
there's there's no doubt about that
that's what I'm saying is that we have
to not count discount the business part
but I'll listen to it and back to the
business part and you mentioned this
addict
if you think that the game devs and the
Publishers aren't when you see the when
you see the recommended spec in the 30
70s why is that because they have an
inherent interest right that the that
the graphics cards manufacturers sell
new graphics cards right all of that all
of that works they all work together you
understand
question I do have for you guys is one
um I personally feel like you know it
would be more probably beneficial to
start rotating off these older cards to
you know make you know the the Floor
Escape for these games higher and two
do you think that a developer not
particularly this developer or just
people in the past that spoke concerned
on making these many type of uh you know
skus to make games do do you think that
they should voice their opinion on the
annoyance of making a game for five or
six different cues because like if you
look at it this is look we've had
different cues all through this time but
this is this is like one of the first
times where you're having it out the
start of the gate uh because you know
the Xbox series X was introduced later
in the Xbox one because like this type
of besides PC this is new to consoles
this isn't something that just happened
in the past 10 years like PC's been
doing that since the beginning
I mean we're not going backwards at it
it's not I mean we're already past that
point in our return it's not going back
to that like so our consoles aren't
going back to that PC is never going to
go to that because the idea is you want
to sell this you want as many people to
access the game as possible so it's just
not going back like the wall Garden
you're talking about on the p on the
console side that wall is broken down
bro the last the really last Bastion of
that is Nintendo and Nintendo is going
to do what they do and not be affected
by what else is going on I think the
biggest takeaway I can make from this is
like look I get it you couldn't hit it
with with 30 uh with 60 on on the series
s that's what this individual was uh
really aiming for from the start he
should have probably just said that
right but it's just like why did Dead
Rising 2 come out at 30 on the the S and
60 on on the X it's like 10 to me you
could have made that work I don't know
like it's just to me other people are
looking at it like look let's let's go
ahead and cap this form this version 30
until post launch so we have the time to
go back because I think it's all time
sensitive right I think they don't have
the time to finish the criminalizing the
game and they're going to do a post
launch but it's like this particular one
it's like they're like we're not going
to even worry about the x or the PS5
like you just you playing it like yeah
you know what I think it is and I saw
flame I'm sorry I know we would keep it
this is good download and and you know
what I remind it reminds me of and I I
want to be respectful because I'm not
trying to sit there and say that yo they
all you know they all capping you know
what I'm saying like no problems with
the series that's it's completely I'm
not doing that what I'm trying to
explain is that game development game
design yes there's challenges to it
there's no doubt about about it what I
what I remember is the 360 and the PS3
era right
and I remember devs was like oh God the
cell with the PS3 the sale process
remember there were certain things I
remember specifically the Bethesda ports
really did not run well I'm just tired
of him on PS3 it was really a problem
but guess what over that generation they
eventually got systems better tooling
better and they were able to start
developing games so they could at least
try to be on parody with the 360. that's
what it feels and I don't even feel like
this is that serious you know what I'm
saying because in this particular case
the gpus and you see what you were to
say hey it's j it's the memory and I'm
not gonna it's the memory yeah that the
memory is such is not an issue yes it is
I'm not going to say it's not but all
I'm saying is there are challenges in
game development with multiple skews
multiple skews have existed for a long
time right and I just think at the start
list we're still fairly new in this
generation at the start of this
generation they are just now figuring
this out if you notice even Xbox
themselves have come out with like
different SQ sqs for um series that's to
try to improve the memory allocation and
stuff like that to make it easier for
them because devs intrinsically want
things to be easier and want to utilize
the most powerful powerful they can
flame at it again I'm sorry
I oh you go ahead and finish
definitely did you want to go no no
you've been patient oh I was just gonna
say like uh one of the comments that I
was seeing like from some of the
developers was just well
developers
I'm sorry it's it's hard not to it's
just whenever it comes to the fact they
were really asking Microsoft or uh
demanding that Microsoft just dropped
Xbox series s support so you're gonna
tell me that the console that I think is
at like what two to one with the with
the series X they're just gonna suddenly
drop that they're going to drop oh yeah
Microsoft yeah yeah they're not going to
drop all those customers just because
the developers don't want to work on
another skill and plus again I can't
emphasize this enough this argument
started over Gotham Knights and I was
listening to some to this Comcast last
name with uh you know Ashley
developer I think it's like his name is
um agent Deli on Twitter like he was
literally saying like the entire game
design literally was like uh outside of
the uh well whenever you go inside it's
basically like um hallway room hallway
room yeah yeah the same boring game
design there's nothing really special
being done and
it's just it's hard to take any of this
seriously whenever it's over this game
yeah I've listed again I haven't played
the game yet so I'll make my own
decisions on it but I did want to listen
to what other people had to say and one
of the things that's interesting is that
I've heard very little about people you
know saying that this untethered
experience is amazing like right it's a
Flames point it feels like they didn't
take the opportunity to run with a
making this type of game in this
franchise their own and it just feels
like it's the same old stuff not even as
polished as before so it's like and I'll
never begrudge a team for taking the
initiative to do something different
even if they fail a little bit and just
but they put the idea out there but not
a single review that I listened to or
read said anything about listen I I know
this the 30 FPS controversy is what it
is but I'm gonna tell you right now this
Co-op is banging I don't hear any of
that yeah I feel like
there's multiple layers to this issue
one issue is they waited so long and the
only reason we find out is because I
heard someone got a copy early and they
exposed the the 30 frame thing and then
then they started confirming with 30
frames it's like look like
I'm on this new kick it's like
if it's the 30th game but I'm not
emotionally attached I'm boycotting that
I'm a boy that's what happens
because it's just like nah like like you
said I'm not going backwards like if
everyone else can offer in performance
one you'd mean it tell me Gotham night
camp like nah like we ain't we ain't
about that you know but golf did not go
to the back of the line
all right and you'll play tail go back
there too oh no no no
if you want me to let you out the bus
you better have 60 frame patch on your
head
it's just it's not gonna happen it's
like I'm not going back to playing 30
frame games it's just not it's not
realistic to me I feel like I the only
way I would play is 60 friend games I'm
emotionally tied to that franchise I
like how we bujuified attic yeah
I don't care I'll pay it on whatever I
don't care if if if like the next Final
Fantasy came out at 30 frames
I'm open with that it's not like I'm
saying I'm boycotting oh no I'm like you
know
go in the back don't tell nobody tell
nobody don't show nobody your frame
count but I'm driving attic what are you
playing this week oh nothing oh nothing
it's a good one I'm glad y'all said the
last point we'll wrap this up the also
you know look some studios they're
poorly optimized the way they handle you
know their ports and that that's a
factor too you know so again not gonna
be disrespectful we hear you know what
you know a few are saying but when we
speak
to a lot of the majority of these devs
and a lot of people with Hardware makers
software makers wave your calls so you I
don't even want you putting that in you
in the world what a favor was a 34.
show me your bills
to just block you for putting down
let's go
feet I smell I smell abandonment yeah
you go baby come out and they say I'm
not even I'm not even putting the energy
of that thing it's not happening like
you go ahead
yeah
I would be devastated you see it's going
back to be one of those things where
it's like you know they they're Midway
through I'll walk through I see the 30
frames on my head it's like I snatch it
and just hand them with 60 frames just
just act like it act negative just act
like it's your final point and this is
the thing too again we're all not all
development studios are made the same
because you have to account also for the
ones that they do account for they see
the what's the word like the disparities
right and think about this generation
how many times we've actually gotten a
performance mode right so to me those
Dev studios are looking at the touch
points and able to say okay we do the
trade-offs here on resolution we could
get we could still achieve that let's
give the gamer that option and to me
that does separate Studios from each
other you know what I mean
also bro okay did you see what Callisto
protocol did what they do oh yeah
it was rumored that their game was going
to get delayed so they had to address
that obviously and they're like look we
are coming out February uh we are coming
out December I don't care what the
internet says we will be there day and
day not February like like these rumors
not only that we will have a performance
and then you know what I did it because
they gave me that that that
energy man you know what I did I caught
Twitter
that's what we got let's get this solve
and move on
document one second
Chad is out of pocket today
uh we got Iron Mike five dollar Super
Chat King doing the Jim Ryan style World
Tour doing everything in his power to
delay that Ragnarok
when I was streaming Persona someone put
in the chat they're like addict there's
review copies out there people got the
game why ain't you took the king's knees
yet but I'm like because I ain't gonna
be able to take King's knees until that
game is out for the public he ain't
doing nothing like that uh but I do want
to bring up that um
I was going to conclude the God of War
giveaway this whip you know I'm gonna
milk it a little bit more you know why I
I I will post the the Tweet again today
and there will be one last week of that
God of War giveaway and after that it's
wrapped keep in mind it's only for uh
North America I think correct yes and
guys keep in mind also having it day one
because obviously you know Sony can't do
anything right away
you know hopefully we'll get in on that
second shipment but they they definitely
said you will not be receiving it by
launch day so that means that the winner
will definitely not be receiving the
balance do you think we should we should
do the the thing for for the thing so we
should wait till next week
let's wait till next week I want more I
want I want more concreteness but either
way we still you know put it out there
you know
let's just
yeah let me read the Super Test hold on
THX 1138 five dollar Super Chat PS4 is
the rotten Spud holding back
consideration these games are designed
the last generation in mine two to three
years transition listen if we want to be
honest and call something an albatross
the albatross is the lowest spec
possible on PC that these games run on
that's the albatross if we really talk
about that talk about it it's it's it's
nonsensical it doesn't make a whole lot
of sense we got a lame member for 25
months what bronze there's an imposter
on your podcast I'm still on the Run for
the horses also I swear I didn't rig the
vote I swear
shout out to that other flame yeah I
don't know who this person is
but he has good points so you know we'll
keep him here it's fine
then we got Phase 23 bkny oh
it has been multiple devs that has
complained about the series s so you
can't deny that some debt what some devs
have said yeah we acknowledge
said that but a lot of it comes down to
your specific situation and the argument
that that we're arguing against is the
fact that this is
this is intrinsic to game design so for
you to be like to point the thing about
one thing but like this is what's
ruining everything it doesn't make also
multiple devs does not suggest majority
of depths depths you have to be clear
yeah so we got Jonas the dad two dollar
Super Chat on a positive note AC Odyssey
on Game Pass is f in five yes you can
see Odyssey is it please make sure
you're playing as Cassandra thank you
yeah that's a big one
there we go spark go 17 two pounds Super
Chat crying for more power won't turn
the trash game to Gold that's another
thing again I haven't played it myself
I'll make my own deductions but um
generally people aren't necessarily so
high I got them nice so yeah mixed
things yes so yeah then we have Jesus
1070 cognives in the story
focus is on CPU with storage brother
yeah hold on hold up
the Persona stream actually I addicts
from yesterday
no doubt it salute then we have day one
new member shout out to Jay won't put
the crust in the chat five dollars for
the chat I can understand why Cog is
Lord acquisition first party Studios
almost always have less technical issues
and have better optimization yeah that
doesn't make sense the first party
Studios should they have the keys to the
castle right
um but again
the majority of games that come out and
the majority games that you play are
third party game third party games like
I said and the switch is still out here
y'all just let y'all know yeah unless
people act like it don't exist the
switch is still out and it gets poor
they just released Alan to wake
remastered on the switch native Native
Native yeah you know people go where the
money's at that's just something yeah
the switch got a 360 game Ronnie
remastered with the money say with the
money
Saints Row is untethered Co-op at 60 FPS
and the thread yes row is
not good okay
there we go face again 23 BK why 20 loss
with Jack Gotham Knights is not a
demanding game it's poorly optimized on
PC this is true and console and wouldn't
be surprised if they released a 60 FPS
performance mode months later like attic
was saying yeah it's probably coming in
hot anyway right so
yeah we have Rick Gaffney two pound
Super Chat first time catching you live
love the Pod fellas thank you appreciate
that much love
then we got Hector the Macho Man five
dollars oh hell the Lords just because
the king isn't here doesn't mean you
don't wipe your feet I appreciate y'all
turkeys thank you
that we got hargit to need remember five
for one year five dollars a chat
Nintendo already has two skews with the
switch docked and undocked that's true
that's real that's real that's another I
forget I forgot about that yo that is
bad real they actually have us they have
more performance in the console version
I mean the deported in the dark version
and they have to account for that it
just that's how game development works
yeah but you know tell tell a business
suit I'm not putting the game on the
switch uh because you know I can't get
it too well how many switches off 150.
oh yeah yeah yes you are you gonna get
in there you go you're gonna make that
before you're gonna make out of Worlds
over there you're gonna make with you
and you're gonna like it get in there
[Music]
save your seventy dollars and buy band
in the three or 60 FPS game yes it will
be a 60 FPS I yes that I do agree with
hold on a second
and jump
we got Dark Side fantasy two dollars to
the chat addict where the Rabbits Review
we need that man did not play Rappers or
something
oh my God
yeah the the iron back did not receive a
request
if we get 350 likes I will review right
and you know what we need these pillows
because I feel you know if you're gonna
do all this gaming you got to be
comfortable with it you gotta let's go
you know what I'm saying you gotta
really do this gaming
put this link in it
if y'all really want to do these things
I see that valari link at the top make
sure y'all go support that you know what
I'm saying my good people Vallarta make
sure your posture is right when you're
doing it you know what I'm saying hit
that truck got that link up at the top
right there the links right there go to
Volaris pin at the top get your gaming
on get real comfortable with it your
posture right continue
pillow talk with the Lords that's right
and there may be additional incentives
coming down
because they hit the numbers it's going
to be right
and we got done a taco five dollar Super
Chat also Mario plus rabbits 2 is the
best term race game this year even
better than triangle strategy flame Lord
turn based you better not sleep
let's go then we got kids move member
for 25 months I don't think 29 months
time flies been playing Persona 5 Royal
I can't believe I'm 10 hours in uh end
of the palace one and still want to play
was not expecting to enjoy this much
apparently shame on you for enjoying the
game James
yeah but I get it you know some of it
some people are very vocal about not
caring about something that's on your
platform but it's just like there's some
people that's huge into like
achievements and stuff so it's just like
if it's not on their platform why are
people come the same people that are
clowning smooth right now for posting
all types of stuff on Persona or the
same people that says that the Xbox
people wouldn't play the game yeah so
it's just like
somebody's arguments
you're a fan base didn't support the
title the title yeah so what do y'all
want yeah yeah I I think it's like we
got to be real too like there's just
remember how we always talk about what
games come to PC and like a lot of
console guys are mad right
it's just some people it they're gonna
prefer to play something on the platform
they like that's just it and they'll
wait however it is that's just how it is
that's some people oh that's fake but
that's where they like to play games and
even if they have that platform already
they won't do it like I've said listen
this is a funny thing right I heard this
morning specifically somebody like
you're not a real gamer if you do that
and you own all the platforms right
tell Colin Moriarty he's not a he's not
a real gamer tell him he's not a real
game right and he'll he'll have the
platform right in his house he's like
I'm playing it on Playstation whenever
it comes yeah when I smoked a column me
and him had a great discussion about it
and he was just like look I'm so
embedded in the ecosystem with trophies
and so he was like for him to come to
Xbox he was like we came up with this
word we call it like smart like you like
smart delivery right right we call it
like like smart entitlements or whatever
it's like right he said it like the
achievements are across all your third
party games to just come over and into
Xbox and they'll the trophies will turn
into achievements right right some
people just like the ecosystem it's just
not that serious not that deep Bro that
and the same thing with PC my thing is I
rather one more people play the game two
yes if they buy the game then guess what
you get more support for a potential
Sequel and other things in the future so
I get it I also do think that you know
some people do feed into it too much
yeah yeah so they're not necessarily
doing it because some people are
contradicting earlier tweets and stuff
they're doing it because they know
they're going to get a response oh yeah
that's just the reality of Twitter right
but I will say the the only thing I will
say is this
Xbox people oh yeah
Xbox people you're getting them games
I'm the one that said there was a cold
day in hell when it was gonna happen and
it happened yeah you got to support it
you need to support if you want to see
more of these games you need to support
if nobody's downloading this if it's not
out there being played in in big numbers
the Xbox you know the higher-ups Xbox
gonna look at this and be like is it
worth it for us you have to absolutely
if you ask for something support it and
it's there it's smooth's enjoying
Persona a lot of you
okay
we got chocolate
remember for nine months Lord bronze
happy Sunday Lords nine months in the
room question of the day can a baby have
forefathers hey yo have a great show
wow messy messy yeah there we go Stitch
uh five dollars to protect Cog I need my
pillow coating for 60 plus hours a week
it's rough I need something to hug me
when fixing bugs
we have something for you guys so for
you exclusive joints coming you know
what I mean remember it's the pre-order
joint top of the Year y'all will get
them we just gotta get over get up get
that over 100 y'all hit that link at the
top of the description man go get that
you get that 15 yeah 15 off before they
get the 100 then you get gotta spend
more bread don't do it I'm gonna put the
link in again just in case y'all forgot
yeah put it in the chat sure and we have
Donald tackle five dollar super chat or
Persona 5 Royal on Xbox and switch and
already have Persona 5 and Royal on PS4
All Steel books secured no doubt you're
a real gamer sir thank you I appreciate
it but that's that's love right there
like you gotta have it everywhere and
you know I will point out this uh we're
still in the early you know uh you know
if if I see some of here here's the
stair I'm just gonna say let's go here
is the scenario all right no we don't
okay just go ahead because the Chicago
already said it's come out as well
we they're going to NYC what's it called
plan so play NYC on November 5th they
want me to go but
I ain't going for free
I gotta travel I gotta drive two hours I
gotta get on a plane stay over there
they already over there okay so if you
guys want an in-person podcast making my
white self get on a above get in a car
drive two hours fly for an additional
two to three wait for Cog to pick me up
from the airport I don't know how long
that take he busy he busy dude you can
take hours then the the how many I'm
gonna need 10 pillars sold uh by the end
of the month I'm gonna need 10 pill or
so and we me Cognito King and soft will
have an in person podcast
we ain't never done that really fine
yeah
no podcast with just us four
and that's up to you guys if you guys
want that get that all right stop
playing ten pill or so between right now
the 23rd and the 30th if it doesn't
happen I'm gonna stay home and play
Persona
I heard the man make it happening yeah
he's been fighting us on this he said
well I gotta go over this one day
already got that pillow shout out to DJ
orange to the building I see y'all you
know all right no doubt no no use the
link make sure y'all use the link to get
the 15 some of y'all are buying it and
we respect it but you're not using the
link the link yes
so you know especially you want me and
King in the same room
that's gonna be something what else we
got what else we got and we got Big Mad
Mo remember for 28 months Lord Brown
shout out to you sir shout out to the
Lords in the realm also Persona 5 is
fired absolutely good to see people
playing the support that's what's up
Super Chat who are who are you guys
Persona 5's waifus
I hear different people standing for
different uh different characters yes I
got a girlfriend that watches these
I'm not too far gone sorry I'll tell you
later buddy
then we got chill Walker remember for 17
months even though Persona 5 is on Game
Pass I still bought the game because I
know I will play it and then back to my
second run of Soul hackers yes sir
peacock Fusion he said rip I missed the
15 get that second one you know what I'm
saying for your you know your special
someone you know
little girl stocking stuffers like I
can't do something
we got JD gamer 20 Super Chat shout out
to the Lords give me a little man on the
screen and understand it's power I got
you a little band outside you know what
I'm saying they came for the kid they
came for the kids they try to get them
up out of here
he's doing his thing he's the most
successful though you're the most
successful you doing this thing most
successful it's a dopable shot to the
gut of PlayStation and that's why
they're over there yapping pretending
like Japan and others aren't running
with the Box pause yeah they are though
here running with the Box we got to be
careful with the liquids
but we respect that JD respect when you
try to go over there anyway
let's get into it y'all so next topic
y'all being at a controversy returns got
some additional information addict this
is your topic I want to get into it man
set me up so much going on right now all
right no doubt no doubt so shout out we
pretty much know the history from last
time which is um you know the actress
came out and I believe her name um was
it Helena Taylor excuse me yeah and
um you know she she has Survivor videos
it went up to 9.5 million views on
Twitter really struck a nerve amongst
Gamers and voice actors and actresses
that are under underpaid
underappreciated you know and it it
started it sparked a lot of debate so
since then shout out to uh Jason
schreier you know what I'm saying from
on Bloomberg and they did something
there's some digging so I said in the
case of uh being in the three developer
appeared to be determined to uh rehire
Taylor according to two people familiar
with the negotiations as well as
documentation review by Bloomberg here's
where the accounts differ from tailors
Platinum getting sought to hire Taylor
for at least five sessions each paying
three thousand to four thousand for four
hours in the studio said to people who
asked not to be identified because they
aren't authorized to discuss private
contract negotiations they would make
that would make the total for the game
at least 15 000. in response they said
Taylor asked for a six-figure sum as
well as residuals on the game Platinum
declined and following lengthy
negotiations took auditions for a new
actor Platinum later offered Taylor a
cameo in the game for the fee of one
session which she turned down the people
set in an email Taylor I guess refuted
describe this account as an absolute lie
and said Platinum was trying to save
there and the game she says she's still
buy everything she said in the video I
would like to put this whole bloody
franchise behind me quite frankly get on
with my life in the theater she wrote
representatives for Platinum Games
Nintendo didn't respond to requests for
comment Hideki Kamia the executive
director of Bayonetta 3 called Taylor's
allegations sad and deplorable in her
Twitter post and yeah I think and then
also since then We Believe Jonathan
Jennifer Haley Jennifer Hale who I guess
you know was now taking over the role
you know she had a statement and she
said I wish her all the joy in the world
I wish oh excuse me excuse me um this
was the initial statement but she was
bad at um Jennifer was what was still
Taylor was still mad at Jennifer Hill
saying that she had no right and
whatever so then since then I believe
she went to Twitter because remember
Hale was uh attacked and said um I
sincerely asked that everyone keep in
mind that this game has been created by
an entire team of hard-working dedicated
people and I hope everyone will keep an
eye open about what they've created a
few hour later since she received a
Twitter thread from another voice actor
saying if you only hear one side or part
of one story you haven't heard the whole
story so it's been a lot that has
happened since then I know ad accepted
ways so we'll take take over for it but
um this guy with you flame like what
what's your thought process now that
more information has come out
you know the Jason Schroder stuff kind
of disputing a little bit as far as um
what the pay discrepancy actually was
you know what you call actually
disputing that saying that that's not
true and then obviously the the person
who has replaced her then coming out
with a statement so what's your feeling
Hollis
well I kind of knew that Jason schreier
was going to come out with a report he
always kind of does he's and so I
appreciate so I actually do want to give
him his flowers and actually being able
to clear the air about this because
the thing that concerns me the most
about um
Helena Taylor's entire stance is the
fact that she literally said like she
wants to put the whole bloody franchise
behind her it's like that's not some in
one in the videos beforehand she was
like very prideful about the game and
that you know nobody has any right to
play this character aside from me and
then another brother's like I just want
to put this whole franchise behind me
like I just don't like that kind of
energy so it's kind of hard to
gauge this
from one side or the other all I could
say is that um
whatever it comes down to this people
are still going to make their decisions
whether or not to boycott you know
people don't people are still going to
start with Helena or platinum games at
the end of the day and all I can really
say is that
if you don't want to support
Bandit a three and
because you feel like Helena has been
wronged by this then
this considered the fact that
um hail will be
hurt by this because if if it doesn't
rage a certain Mouse it doesn't reach
like sales Milestones won't go about it
but um in terms of like the
so that the inconsistency with like the
story I think if anything she could have
disputed that she probably didn't get
the call for the first
um
roll or whatever because like this like
Plano said like they try to get her back
the first time around but she's not
mentioning that so maybe she
so maybe there was like something lost
like in the emails or something like
that I don't know maybe she didn't get
the first one for the role and then she
only got the call for the Cameo
believing it was for the whole roll or
something like that but I don't know how
you would get that mixed up so it's kind
of
a lot of stuff going on and we still not
all privy to but we obviously got some
more inside reporting from from Jesus
fryer Bluebird soft what are you
thinking now this additional information
has come out you know in reference to
Insider staining you know what Helena
got paid and then obviously coming to
disputing that in conduction with
Jennifer's you know response as well
um
well first off you know the people
saying that she's you know immediately
jumping to the conclusion that she lied
um
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
because even if there was a gross
misunderstanding of what they offered
her
if the base rate even though you'd
expect an actress like her not to
receive the base rate if the base rate
was still a thousand dollars and they
said that recording would be anywhere
from four to five sessions it makes
sense that she would might understand
that they only offered him four thousand
dollars for the whole thing right it
still makes sense so there's still a
scenario where being offered four
thousand dollars makes sense so for
people to just jump on be like oh she
was obviously lying doesn't make a whole
lot of sense to me um what about
omission
that's the thing right the weird part is
be if you're gonna come out and sail
this thing these things and you want
them to be you're asking people to
boycott the game but yes clear and
concise with what you're saying as
possible if you specifically come out
and say yeah there's x amount of
sessions I would be doing and they
offered me x amount of money per session
then there's no question her whatsoever
so omitting that absolutely does not
look good on her part so ultimately
either there was gross miscommunication
across all parties here or somebody's
life right
and that's where like for this point
it's hard to even really come down on
this on one side or the other because
now it comes down to he said she said
right and and that's all it is it's it's
conjecture it's we don't have any real
proof either way because you know you
know if if if they if Platinum really
felt that their game would be in
Jeopardy by what's going on here
who's to say they're they're they're not
above doctoring
and showing them who who is to say right
who is to say I'm going to be perfectly
honest I I don't you should not trust
companies period like you just shouldn't
like they have their best interest at
heart whatever that that may be
um
assuming
um uh you know assuming levels of
Integrity from big companies or
companies in general it's just it's hard
to do because it's an entity not an
individual right it's not a person it's
an entity and they're going to do what
they need to do to protect the entity
um unless you know the evidence out
there is so absolutely you know
unapproachable that you just you can't
do anything but admit to it so yeah this
is a tough one because again it just
feels in my mind somebody's lying or
they just you know the language barriers
or whatever the hell she she
misunderstood she understood something
completely different than to what they
were trying to present to her but again
it that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense either because they've dealt with
each other for years at this point and
you know if there's some gross
misunderstanding about what they're
offering to pay you you you want to make
sure that you go back to the table like
hey is this what you're saying like is
this what so
it doesn't make sense that there was
this gross misunderstanding so uh sadly
it feels like somebody's lying and will
never really know the truth of this so
end of the day I think general you know
Jennifer Hale took the high road as she
should have
um
because you don't want to get into back
and forth with Helena we talked about
this last week how you know I understand
her personal reasons and and respect
that at the same time
that character is not yours you don't
own anything right about that character
you can the character's voice and image
everything about it is Iconic in that in
in that it's recognizable to anybody
who's played those games or played video
games you know what Bayonetta sounds
like you've heard her in you know Smash
Brothers and her own games so there's
there is an iconic nature to that
character you don't own the character
unfortunately it's just not the case I
mean if David hater can be replaced a
solid snake
you're replaceable in that regard so
that that sort of rant that she went on
afterwards I I can't abide by that I
can't yeah I think that
look these voice actors are very
talented a lot of them have very unique
name uh voices
but it's just like you said
you're good but there's someone that
sounds just like you like it's just like
you know
everyone's replaceable in every form of
fashion there's always someone else
who's willing to do what you're willing
to do even cheaper than you're willing
to do it so it's just like sometimes you
gotta humble yourself it's just like I
did I just
she had every right to deny that money
but what she didn't have the right to do
was encourage people not to only support
Bayonetta three
she told the actress that took over the
vein at a mantle that you have no right
signing posters as Bayonetta which who
is she to even say that she has the
right you didn't make the character you
voiced the character you were in the
room writing for the character it's not
like you created it so you decided to
voice it look like yeah that's the crazy
part all you did was voice it like look
you brought it to life no one's ever
gonna take that away from you you
brought that character to the light but
we've seen it over and over again you
know especially in anime
they'll switch people and you could tell
the voice has changed but after a couple
months nobody says anything ever again I
want to read Josh something just because
you know Cox always got to be Devil's
Advocate against it I want to know what
y'all think so this is again from uh
schreier in the in the article Game
actors have long uh complained of being
underpaid and underappreciated some have
said they received little information
about their roles until they show up
actually in the recording booth the
industry operates as such clandestine
ways that actors sometimes won't even
know what game they're recording lines
for until it's released detentions last
crested during contract negotiations in
2016 when the union represented many
voice actors discrete Actors Guild and
American Federation of television and
radio artists orchestrated a strike that
lasted nearly a year one of the sticking
points was residuals which we know she
asked for allegedly was she she had
asked for a part of her negotiation
meaning compensation for actors with
sales of a game outperform expectations
voice actors gave up that fight the
residuals in exchange for receiving
bonuses based on the number of sessions
they were so does any of that change
your thought process where you might not
know what you're going to get paid when
you step into the booth and also another
Factor they said you don't know what
your character is going to be until you
step in the booth do they say pay they
say as far as the industry operations
such I'm going to get into that too I'm
gonna get to that so there's another
article that talked about the union
aspect right inside the game's industry
business it says generally union
membership for voice actors is
encouraged for the same phrases it is
everywhere else unions hold collective
bargaining power and unions contracts
not only negotiate and renegotiate
contract for rates but also make sure
performers receive health insurance
pension and overtime minimum agreements
ensure that no matter for how long a
performer actually works they receive a
minimum flat rate there is a chance for
actors to be paid use fees or one-time
fee Akai plays for the continued use of
a performance additional money an actor
can make is based on the revenue of the
game or piece of animations that are
called residuals its members agree to
not only work on projects that honor
Union contracts in order to not undercut
each other and defeat the purpose of the
unions but what do you do group of a lot
of the projects you want to work on
don't offer Union contracts and then it
talks about you know the popularity of
an actor and if this game is like
could be a big time game but it's not
Union supported right so basically is
the short-term game of a non-union
project like a role of the popular
gaming franchise preferable to the state
of stability of what a union stands for
and that basically the dichotomy of like
doing the Union game you know and versus
the non-unit with the potential maybe to
get more bread and then the whole idea
of you know coming in and not really
knowing I see people in the comment
section taking context I said uh look I
never said this I literally said as
Justified she shouldn't have took that
four thousand dollars and it was rumored
that you know Jason schreier said that
she was offered four thousand dollars a
session right yeah so it's just like
look like
I don't there this is this is a what's
wrong I'm looking for a very
weird situation because at the end of
the day we don't know everything a
hundred percent and it's just like
it's sad that she pulled like someone
put in the chest she poisoned her own
well by not being transparent with
everything that was going down because I
still think that you know four thousand
dollars a session is too is not much
like you know what they do and it's just
like
but what do you possibly do from that do
you do you refuse to do the work do you
Refuge do you refuse to work into the
industry until you get a United States
like because then at that point you're
gonna have what happened last time where
some people break the picket fence and
they get all the jobs so it's just like
it's a it's a fighting hell about it
because I know for a fact that you know
the hosting thing where you see people
host events they get paid more than that
so and it's just like
if they could go out there for a couple
days get paid that kind of money why
can't there be more of a conversation on
the voices that bring the video game
characters that we love to like that's
all I wanted to say and that I mean that
was literally my boss because I just
feel like
we got to be we don't know everything
here right but we got I love what you
said at it because we got to be careful
because at the end of the day like
you could play a game against the
graphics we get it right we we get all
these other aspects but there are iconic
characters because of these voice actors
and actually for sure right and for them
to be the pay scale to be that
disparaging the disparity between as if
what they doing is not really popping
towards games and I remember the Uproar
when there wasn't no Michael iron sides
and I'm gonna tell y'all right now the
day something happened god with Steve
downs and there's a Steve down situation
and you don't hear that iconic voice for
chief you know what I'm saying or
there's a situation with a lot of I'm
telling you it people Gamers really care
about that stuff and I just don't want
to get I don't I know I don't know all
the specifics and who's lying here and
I'm going to be respectful of Jason we
know his report is official you know
what I'm saying like but I just don't
want to
undervalue what voice actors and
actresses do you and that they should
try to fight for their back that's what
I'm saying whether or not come on yeah I
I think it's a shame that all of them
don't fight well he's like some of them
made it then they were like look like
that's your fight and it's just like
yeah and that's me if they all would
come together they would win in a date
yeah and I mentioned
realistically have that happening it's
sad man because it's just like I do feel
like this particular incident was more
on the actual actress I don't know the
way I get the vibe they didn't want to
work with her you know they they offered
her that as you've done this to our
franchise you know here's our offer and
she should have just took that and left
you know and then speak speak about it
when it comes out you could even say
boycotting because I don't think
she was wrong and saying you should boy
got the game because she felt they did
her wrong where I felt like she went
over the line is when you started
attacking another person playing the
character that you denied the paycheck
for so it's just like that that that's
it's a gray area man it's a hard area to
navigate through and I you know and I
hate it for a lot of these people and
then apparently like if you want to get
paid like decent money you have to play
multiple people yeah yeah and it's just
like look like
you got to be more vocal with that stuff
like I I've always said it over and over
again social media will make
multi-billion dollar corporations
cave long before stance is like I'm not
gonna take that put if she would have
collectively went to like an IGN or
something with like 10 of her friends
that's been through something similar
and you start we're running with that
story that's going to get way more
published than coming out because
because first off you waited till Bay
night it was about to drop so it looked
like he was doing something
intentionally to hurt Bayonetta instead
of coming out there because you're gonna
break the NDA regardless yeah so you
might as well have done it months ago
yeah that NDA is broke that's for sure
and I I hate to think I do think that
she's blacklisted she will never work in
this industry again uh she not only did
she leave out information she came out
openly and said uh for another actress
that is just looking for today just
looking to work that she had no right to
sign stuff then it's just like
the part that just irritates me that's
the part that just I I can't I can't get
down with her with it's like
you didn't write the character see you
don't even really have the right to go
out there and write Satan you're a
bayonet you've always been at it and
they allow you to go out there and
inside stuff with all sense of reality
the person who wrote Bayonetta should
have been signing those posters it's
just you voice them so yeah it's just
like it's a hard thing I do feel like
there's some form of entitlement with
this situation uh I I do feel like she
is entitled to want more money but at
the same time there's a line and I do
feel like she crossed it by saying the
person who did take the money that you
had no right taking that money you
should have let Bayonetta die it's a
tattoo it's a test I mean I got all the
balls I wanted to get off I just want to
hit y'all with that joint yeah I just
you know look one aspect you know she
put herself out there there's going to
be repercussions with that on another
aspect I do feel that maybe this shines
a light on what's going on with all this
undisclosed aspects of of paid and as
far as voice acting and voice actresses
and you know hopefully they can get
fight for a bigger bag you know what I'm
saying because these are the iconic
characters that we love you know
straight up like yeah you know that I
think that's the conversation that needs
to happen and it just it's sad that it's
marred by this
um and like you know the same thing that
addict said that I mentioned last week
as well it's just like I don't I don't
want to see I don't want to see the
Press soap boxing for this stuff I want
to see the people that it's affected
soap boxing for this stuff and come
together to fight you know and I it I
know that's easier said than done but
honestly you do anything especially
especially the the climate that gaming
is in right now trying to get away from
from all the the the the Bad actors that
whatever Activision whatever Ubisoft all
that stuff like you coming together as a
collective to say hey we need to be
better about this is not going to get
the same reaction that it used to where
they just Blacklist you and you fire you
or whatever and nobody says anything
that's not gonna happen anymore the sad
part about it is the industry the gaming
industry in general is very sensitive to
anything
you know if you come out you can get
fired just by speaking an opinion on
Twitter uh you can get fired for
speaking on
uh you know toxic environments that you
work in you can get fired on doing just
about anything and the fact that ndas
are throwing around so loosely in the
industry like the moment anything wrong
goes wrong make her sign an NDA we're
like she gonna shut up she ain't going
outside the screws they're talking our
business
it was just like I feel like that might
be more of the issue that stuff don't
get fixed because when you have these
other actors and actresses trying to
make it in this industry they can't come
out there because they're too scared to
lose their spot in the industry and then
you put that on people that's been doing
it for years and this is their only
source of income that's the only thing
they know I don't blame them for not
wanting to be vocalizing about stuff
like that because it's like look they
might not like the scenario they're in
but they're looking at the future I
can't get to that future if I start
throwing out stuff now and I get
blacklisted before that even happens and
it's just like the stuff that you seen
with Sony where people are not even
asking for God War reviews because they
know Sony's because apparently there was
an outlet that said that they didn't
yeah well apparently like what happened
was Sony gave them a Ratchet and Clank
review and they said things they didn't
like about it and when they when they
asked about it in the email they Sony PR
said we didn't like your tone uh so
yeah Escapist so they didn't even ask
for a God of War review because they're
like look I reviewed your game I don't
care how you like my tone or not and
we've seen Sony on multiple occasions
like I wouldn't say sensor but they're
being selective on who they give
information out to who they give review
copies to then it's just like you know
when stuff like that happens like
influencers you know a lot of people
wonder why influencers roll the way they
they wrote the same reason the voice
actors were the way they wrote Because
all it takes is one bad tweet and you
blacklist it for the whole industry yeah
it's it's real out here in these streets
that's all I got flavor anybody else got
anything else before we move on from the
bayoneta three updated controversy
situation that's funny we kept getting
updates to Old controversies that's been
like the news for the past month
speaking of which coming up next coming
up next it will be enough this is this
is literally like uh like uh what what
do they call when you update a story
like on the news and stuff I don't know
it's literally every topic we have is an
updated story of this I can't help it
it's all let's start talking about guys
like you know they they ain't a lot to
really talk about unless I want to talk
about Gotham nice is bad game for 30 40
minutes
oh yeah a couple super chats uh let me
play with you
can I be your persona wife
I go five dollars a check what's this
the internet overreacted to hearing one
side of the story and then it ended up
being a lie oh this is unprecedented
wait no one said he was alive we just
did it don't be a messy I see you dog
there we go Mr Nichols five dollars this
is the same company that screwed Xbox on
scalebound I believe her oh he ride it
he rotted that's right
I smell what you putting down but I
stand with homegirl in this situation
not right for her to say boycotta at the
same time if it was your girl why could
be from your girl I mean I I would be
very blessed to have a girl doing voice
acting like that but that's besides the
point uh like like look like
we got to get to the point where it's
like
I can still agree with the message she
got that I just don't agree how she did
it oh shout out to a robin is gifting
them five IOP memberships yes salute if
I honestly truly feel like she she could
have got her point across
and it didn't look like oh really look
like the way she did it she was salty
the game was coming out she was trying
to stop dogs again and that's that's the
rest of the things
if she if six seven months ago she came
out and she was vocal about what
happened then it would be like look okay
you break but it's she's strategically
waited till the game was about to come
out before she made any kind of
statement because she wanted to sabotage
the game that
this story shouldn't have been about
Bayonetta three should have been about
the money that went into paying her for
Bayonetta three instead of tackling it
from that situation she said look they
didn't give me what I wanted boycott it
let's stop let's let the game flop then
it's like why would you even care about
her signing posters on Bayonetta three
if you if you didn't care about the game
succeeding first for a third one so you
don't care about Bayonetta as a
character you care about you playing
bayonet as a character
I think it all comes down to the like
whatever comes to like the backlash is
getting now I think it comes down to the
fact that she talked way too much I
think that first video that she made the
one that you know started the whole
thing I think that was fine it could
have given her a good sympathetic angle
right so a degree but the moment that
she started talking more and more in
some of the response she gave that's the
whole reason why this is starting to
flip on her head and what you know she
had like yeah if you get in trouble it's
just like don't talk too much only say
what you need to say and then they
respond if you're asked something don't
don't go too far and I honestly feel
like you know if she would have just
made this about
how she felt unjust on how she got paid
then I feel like
for the majority of the point even when
they dropped the other foot she should
sure so she should have been very vocal
about if Jason schreier is right getting
paid 4
000 a session that's way different than
being 4 000 for the entire set all the
session and I felt like she tried to
like you know try okay I got paid four
I'm not gonna mention it was for each
session and it's just like you know I
agree they deserve more money uh you
know apparently Jason schreiss says she
asked for a hundred grand like Plus or
something like that like it's just like
there is a point where your ego is
probably judging with realistic was not
realistic and I do feel like she felt
like she deserved 100 Grand because the
the game made 450 million dollars
apparently all of them did it's just
like but but you're not
that all that profit isn't just paying
you it's paying the artist that Drew the
game it's paying the other voice actors
of the franchise which is interesting
none of them talked about it at all like
I the the one that replaced yours that
you she's not gonna talk about it and
it's just like the it's paying the
programmers this program in the game the
marketing that's going into the game
like it's not just simple it made 450
million I should have made more money
you were the prime person that did it
you should have made more than they
offered you but it's just like that's as
far as that should have went
it's gonna be a very interesting
situation man Jason I've been watching
that too and I'll just read one last one
he said because I forgot to mention it
he said clearing up two misconceptions
as a voice Act of 4K for four hours
doesn't actually translate to 1K per
hour consider taxes agent fees expenses
and unpaid time between gigs two full
bayoneta sales aren't public but it's
niche uh abandoned into two on switch so
1 million less than most Nintendo games
then he goes on to say agent fees are
absolutely not paid by the hiring side
an unpaid time between gigs is something
that has to be taken into account when
comparing the job pay of a job like this
to a normal salary position okay so
being at a two on switch selling a
million copies a game that originally
released on the Wii U that's kind of
that's a lot
but he said lower than most Nintendo
games right so it's a re-release what I
will say is the only thing I kind of
disagree with a little bit is like the
paid between gigs because like it would
be different if he was going like if you
were staying let's say that someone is
always going to be voice acting like a
particular company like 2K Nintendo
that's one thing but I feel like these
people have the
they could jump around as much as they
want so it's just like if you don't work
six years and you go from like 2K to
like let's say let's say Microsoft
should Microsoft have to pay you more
money because you weren't working that
six years because you because you didn't
get any other gigs like I feel like that
that's a gray area should companies be
responsible because you didn't get any
other games before I get your own
responsibility but also we gotta we
can't underestimate opportunity if
there's no opportunities if you let's
say you interviewing and you losing out
you know or you know you runner up a
couple times you don't land other gigs
you know I'm saying so now you go
through a stretch maybe you I'm just I'm
just guessing I'm not saying this to
happen you know I'm saying that you go
through a period where it's like yo
you're just not getting gigs like you
trying to land a joint so now you
finally get your next joint so you're
like yo you know what I'm saying I I got
to try to cash out that's what it was
she she hasn't worked a whole whole lot
in the bay since the Bayonetta franchise
and I think she was just trying to get
that big big page remember they ended up
blowing up in her face remember they
didn't get residuals because so if the
game
and y'all you voice a character that's
now iconic and the way they negotiated
their Union they don't get no residual
so this this game exceeds expectations
doesn't rock star I think they pay their
voice actor residuals because GTA 5 I
heard that uh one of the people in GTA 5
like he hasn't worked at all because
he's been living off those from GTA it
could be it depends on my understanding
of a junior or non-union and what the
negotiatives were on that but I just
wanted to throw that in because I forgot
to mention I guess I'm sorry
I don't know that was it I mean again
it's just it's one of those things where
it's like
you have certain guidelines that these
companies go by right and and and
as we've seen they're kind of on the low
side every every different artist has
the right to sort of negotiate within
those guidelines to go beyond those
guidelines but again what I feel is like
if if a Troy Baker or Jennifer Hale or
whoever these more you know uh Nolan
North they if they get Beyond whatever
those base guidelines are right
yeah I just don't see them joining that
fight to make sure
right and it is that thing of like
there's too much silence around this and
to me Jason schreier or other people
writing articles about it and again I
love Jason I love I love the fact that
when it comes people can say whatever
they want about Jason when he comes with
facts
reporting and when he's wrong wrong
facts so
um the fact of the matter is that
ultimately it's sad that that the
conversation around this is this and
what she said and how she said it as
opposed to hey we all need to fight for
this together and I don't know that
conversation is ever going to happen
that's the that's the part about it it's
kind of I don't think it's going to it
y'all talking too long on this good good
thing we choose how long yeah
I mean he's not wrong on this but it's
just like look like this is a very like
broad spectrum topic it's not just like
a simple like this CMA bull snap we
about to talk about literally like we
just got to repeat half the stuff we
said the past two weeks
akw say time
anymore
yeah hold on a second we got a couple
more
we got no actually hold on okay I have
to go back to the main thing no doubt no
doubt we got uh don't know Taco five
dollars Super Chat also I'm pretty sure
Bayonetta will have uh less dialogue in
three versus the previous games because
she has to split screen screen time with
the new main character that's another
thing so they were moving feels like
they're moving on from Bayonetta as the
main character or at least you know
maybe for the next couple games whatever
the case may be
um so I don't know call Andrew's Junior
five dollars super chat if this is how
you treat this bayonet that's the
opportunity you can forget about Halo 6
wow yeah that's it that's what we go
down let's get to it
spicy one very spicy spicy one let's let
me fix my screens we got some visitors
here you know what I'm saying Lord's
gaming.net you know what I'm saying
fully represented right now to log net
in the business it's a beautiful thing
awesome beautiful thing along that's it
but um yeah we gotta get to it y'all we
gotta get to it I mean
the uh the long-standing
UK CMA
Microsoft Activision Blizzard King Deal
or No Deal adequate or no adequate and
now we asking for public assistance
y'all Public Assistance has been asked
for let's get right to it this is the
juiciest thing right now you know what I
mean so look man shout out to lost the
game without net right now just got a
shout out in the building Lord Steve
Perry in the building salute sir check
your levels real quick before I start
talking how your level so hello there we
go there we go great where's my where's
my song man where's my song
but we got to get to it so um yeah shout
out to gamesindustry.biz man the CMA
calls on the public for its views on
Microsoft's acquisition of Activision
Blizzard UK regulator said that open
comments can be provided for its
eventual provisional findings and yeah
this comes a week after they released a
statement which kind of detailed its
concerns over the merger and dismissed
Xbox arguments over aspects like Call of
Duty exclusivity at this point UK
regulator says we invite anyone
including members of the public to share
their views with us so yeah this this
has been a a hot one and and things have
have resonated in our very own you know
Steve has jumped in so I'm gonna start
with you because you you actually had an
open letter on lawsagaming.net in
reference to this so one
you know what are your thoughts on them
opening it up to the public first and
then two let's talk about what you wrote
which has literally broken our sight and
gone viral right now so this start with
the first part what do you think about
the the decision to open it up to the
public uh well number one I do not envy
whoever it is it's a man in that email
address right now because I'm sure he's
been getting a lot of uh a lot of you
know just basically hate messages from
Fanboys on both sides just saying like
oh you're an idiot for even talking
about this oh
um but I think that uh honestly I think
it was a really cool opportunity even
just to you know be somebody from across
across the ocean who will also be
affected by their decision um being able
to kind of chime in and
um and just share my two cents or 20
cents because it was kind of a longer
piece
um but uh yeah so it was it was I think
it's it's cool that that's part of their
process for for folks like me to be able
to just
share our thoughts no doubt no doubt and
then your piece which is uh invoked a
lot of a lot of positivity I would say
overall you know I felt like um the
feedback I've seen has been I think even
just for Windows Central or retweeted
you said well written you know a lot a
lot of people felt that you articulated
your points very well you know for those
who haven't read it and we encourage you
go to the Lord's gaming.net right now
and get your behind over there and read
that but thanks in the chat all right
yeah go check that out man excellent
read but just like to summarize the
paraphrase right you know what what's
your mindset coming because one of the
things that you mentioned was that your
decision making on coming into this
generation played a part as well so a
lot of me talking for you you you you're
feeling kind of on that yeah yeah I will
appreciate it and first of all I gotta
shout out Hogue law I feel like over the
last since this thing got started I've
just learned so much about the process
from him and so much about what
Regulators actually look at
um and so I think the you know like I
said real and brief because I don't want
to don't want to take up the next hour
so I'm just given the breakdown of the
article in full
um but uh together in brief I just think
that it hits like I kind of Hit the
three points of concern that the that
the CMA kind of noted that they were
looking at which was how it was going to
impact competition and consoles how it's
going to impact competition and
subscriptions and how it was going to
impact competition in like a future of
cloud gaming
um and I kind of just talked about how
in my view um the potential benefits of
this of this transaction are uh are
greater than the potential than the
potential risks and also more likely
um and like when I talked about the
consoles like I talked about how you
know with Sony and it's with its current
kind of market dominance is able to make
some decisions that aren't to the
benefit of consumers but are to the
benefit of them as a company which is
their job right just to benefit
themselves
um and I talked about how you know if
um this acquisition were to lead to
closer competition between the consoles
than
um you know
then Xbox would not just become a strong
competitor but a threatening competitor
and Sony would have to start to compete
for its um for its consumers dollars a
little bit harder which is going to
benefit both so into consumers and
Xboxes
um I also just talked about uh you know
without without going into too much of
how much I am a fan of the service I
talked briefly about how I think that
game pass is going to be
um
that game pass being a stronger
um even taking a stronger Market
position in subscriptions doesn't mean
that Xbox is taking a stronger Market
position
um in uh in the market as a whole gotcha
um so again it becomes a dominant
subscription it doesn't mean that Sony
is not going to be able to compete in
other ways
um and then the last thought which I
thought was kind of like their an
addressing of their weakest like the
weakest point of concern for them was
about the future of cloud gaming
um because I think that like that is
such like a new technology and you know
consumers haven't really adopted it on
mass and to any extent yet and so one of
the things that I learned from Hogue is
that typically speaking a Regulators
really reticent to um to kind of snuff
out a potentially growing industry or
potentially growing consumer option so I
kind of pointed out how like you know
this Cloud you know maybe that maybe in
some hypothetical future Cloud will be
dominant and Microsoft will be dominant
in Cloud but we are way too far away
from that for you guys to be making
decisions that might end up
um kind of
slowing or preventing consumer adoption
of a technology that might benefit the
industry in the long run
um so that's uh that's the the article
in brief there I said I hate I see the
bars
let's get played man let's give it that
day but obviously you read Lord Steve's
article and I want to focus first on the
public part you know say I I just I want
to get your thoughts on that like what
was your thoughts when you say yo CMA
said if you want to talk about this we
hear you so what are your thoughts on
that part
uh so did we even hear a peep from the
CMA about the Bethesda deal
not necessarily but In fairness to the
CMA I for my for my understanding this
going public is not unprecedented they
have done this before so okay that
that's the only thing which I was
surprised to hear to be honest I was
like wow this is something they do like
okay
yeah I was just gonna say like man you
why did you guys only speak up now you
guys could guys get this book up last
time but hey when they asked him they
asked if a lake to launch Steve's
article hold on I got you I got you
right there
I just put it in the game so they ask
you to continue but um anyways back to
what I was saying though it's just like
it's weird because while I do like the
idea that the authorities are
because they are the authority on like
the whole deal in their in their
specific region like I actually
appreciate that they do want to listen
to the people who would be affected by
this AKA PlayStation fans mostly and
then Xbox fans who
you know
might want to get more out of their
you know Game Pass deal and everything
like that that's you know it's it's good
to see them actually doing that but at
the same time it's kind of worrying that
they can't just take the
the overall evidence that's been
provided to them by both parties
affected you know PlayStation and Xbox
and just kind of make a decision on
their own it's it's kind of weird it
feels like it's more trying to create an
entire like media circus than anything
else that's why they don't want to take
the information presented by both
parties it's just really weird like
obviously if they didn't do this we
wouldn't have gotten Steve's awesome
piece
you know you had people like Hopewell
making literally an all-day stream
literally
it's breaking down everything that's
coming out of this it's just kind of
it's gotten to the point where it's just
like you guys just got a budge just look
at everything if you want to block it
I'm sure Xbox will take you to Microsoft
will take you before they keep trying to
separate them like Microsoft will take
it Accord over it and see if it gets
overturned because historically a lot of
their conclusions have gotten overturned
anyways so it's not like it's going to
be that much of a big deal the only
thing that I would actually want to look
out for is um other reasons or other
regions like the regulatory bodies in
the FTC I kind of want to see what they
would do yeah that's exactly it and this
is that in this exact situation it's
like the CMA wants to get more of like a
publicity something going because
they're kind of like a smaller region
anyways but um you know it's important
that they do their due diligence and I
do want to see what's going to happen
with the FTC because that's going to be
an even more interesting thing because
the US is much bigger and there's more
spicy politicians in there these days so
yeah this is going to be an interesting
development assistant continue to plague
out in the media sphere Lord addict are
you spitting your bars are you ready to
get in front of the CM and tell them how
you feel but overall how do you feel
about them opening it up to the public
look man it's the CMAs clearly viable
I'm buyable CMA
clearly you willing to listen to Sony
you know I mean look listen to The Attic
oh wow here we go my PayPal Here We Go
relax yourself sir relax yourself I'll
speak all positive you know yeah you
PayPal me enough money I say too you
know not being worked with 10 pieces of
silver sir continue
I don't know you might not be buying for
10 pieces and stuff all right
I had to get in the bag that's it and
I've been waiting my whole life
oh boy couldn't sell out let's go
CMA is clearly taking paycheck oh so you
know I don't know let's go wow my my
email is in the description see you man
how ridiculous you know for a little bit
more my Twitter could be bought too
it's like at this point it's just like
it's a joke it's a parody so it's just
like you know if something like that's
happening you know the only thing I
could think of is people being bought so
that's why I'm saying I am available CMA
and Sony you know if you drop in a
little bit more of a paycheck you know
all you got to do send me a review go
for God of War that's all you gotta do
yeah this guy right here gonna shut his
bike off in a minute he out of pocket
My Views got to be Iron Lord's podcast
but it's not so it's just my bag
fair enough and attic has spoken so
clearly go move on um
opening up to the remember Sony my
PayPal is in the description
[Music]
your feelings are this situation
I don't know man it's just like a real
beta boy situation to me
because
the maid wants us to do their job
before before this deal goes 1.0 they
gotta have our input on it
the deal is an earlier
you know my input on this is this is in
the description
this is not a fully finished
organization this is this is not we're
in the Alpha and the beta okay we're in
the alpha the beta stages of your APK
you know what I'm saying 1.0 is is
this is baffling to me and I I
appreciate state of Steve's article and
his story because he he outlines all the
all of the sort of
everything that we as Gamers reasonable
Gamers see
listen you guys kind of you're focusing
on things that essentially what you're
saying is in order to to stop a
perceived change in sort of perceive
attack on competition now you're willing
to destroy potentially where the entire
industry is going
and so
I I I read the article I read his letter
and I I appreciate everything about
because I think it is it is necessary
that they get that point of view
like we were discussing before we went
live it's like I am so tired of this
because we're talking about things that
we should have no idea uh going on none
of this like and this is what bothers me
and not to say like I
I appreciate that the peak behind the
curtain right but it's gotten so petty
and and sort of the public forum that
I'm just done with it
um because ultimately I think what
happens is that the deal goes through
and the deal goes through with some
concessions what what if PS4 Pony six
six and Xbox 334 could they write the
strong compelling argument and they get
Steve out of there
listen man Xbox one
and PlayStation pony236. you know what I
had the bars ready at that point you
know they only got one person to blame
for that that Sony for that back in that
truck up and getting my PayPal hey
this is
this is the funny thing about it too
right I I don't recall if it's them uh
CMA that have made statements they made
statements that have pointed directly to
what influencers have said like oh this
person's Twitter page and they indicated
this and they got this sort of response
and I'm like what the hell are you doing
first of all I was super shocked when I
saw the CMA posting on Twitter I was
like wait a minute what is this yeah
we're looking into this thing don't
worry about it like and I'm like this
was months ago and I'm like what the
hell why is this out there like that
like this none of this makes any sense
and I I'm just again I I did not mind
the peak behind the curtain to see
what's going on because hopefully what
it was supposed to do is show everyone
this commenting on this that don't trust
companies they all do what they have to
do to to get what they need to get done
in their best interest for their
shareholders for at the end of the day
don't trust them right you should not
put their trust in them in that way
um be critical of the things you love
because chances are they're lying about
something and that's just that's just a
fact of it
um so again I'm really done with this
conversation and and this to me was like
the Tipping Point destroying both the
candles back we gotta go to the public
songs
for you I need to go to the dude in the
street it's like Twitter
it's like Jim Ryan saying yo there's
nobody over here that could do anything
like Call of Duty there's nobody this
nobody in the CMA they could research
this and get real answers behind the
scenes listen if you want to poll if you
want to pull people behind the scenes go
ahead do this they'll be like hey
write to this email address and again
they've done it if you hear me.com
they've done it already and I and I hope
the majority of and this is this is hope
against hope here right because it's
talking about Twitter we're talking
about my hope is that the majority of
responses are measured and uh yes
logical much like Steve's that's like
Steve yes
that is asking a lot
that's all about balls would that's why
I thought this was the most hilarious
thing ever because you gonna get the
entire Fanboy narrative
infiltrating and bad boy cabal yeah like
you're literally gonna be like oh work
we can swayed it because like what if
Jim told them that it's like just just
leaking online just say like I need your
help it's like all right trotting up
hold on one second that joint is funny
to me now granted you know obviously we
got the amazing Steve here you know
articulated his points very well very
respectful by the way sir very very
respectful not full of emotion and all
type of if you read people read the
article you see intelligence
written very well yes but this is the
sad part is we know they not gonna be a
lot of Articles it's like this they're
gonna be like hey yo Xbox ain't got no
games
the SSD is trash for PlayStation and and
they're gonna have all they're gonna
have the avatars with the pictures you
know what they do with the pictures
Emojis with a proper brother
Jersey on when they writing it and I
just I feel for the CMA I feel for the
person or the department that's fueled
a few bills that he got the deal with
this because they about to learn they
going yeah today
the right idea this was is getting fired
no idea the horn is nothing shaving
Twitter facts it's just because gamers
are out of pocket I love it you love me
attic you love it I love the gaming
Twitter gaming Twitter is out of five I
just thought this was the funniest thing
ever so I had to talk about it you know
what I'm saying they gonna learn okay
it's just funny how it escalates every
week you think they're done right and
it's gonna get quiet 30 minute drama
every week bro it really is like it
really is like a subsequent episodes of
24 right
the next hour
absolutely the next episode of IOP this
will come back next week and find out
how the bayoneta drama conclude
but it's the gift that keeps giving it
it just it just it it continues on and
then tune in next week you know what I'm
saying a CMA House of dragons and see
who's gonna fight
I will tell the room right now if
there's a development in CMA or
Bayonetta next week
yes please please I am honored because
For the first time in my life I had the
PlayStation Bob on Twitter come after me
for my work and that just seems like you
made it baby
you've elevated
when they make the video about you they
clip and they put the video and then
it's all I enlarge crying like when you
get down you lit bro you made it bro
you know the uh the meme where it shows
like the Pirates thing and yeah he's
about to get hung and the other dude
gets up and he's like oh your first time
I was like welcome to Breaking the
internet
absolutely brother well written well I
make the match like once a week oh yeah
just getting my feet wet just getting
your feet wet they got flame no oh flame
got it oh I I had to move man yeah yeah
they got you anyways which article was
it too I forgot it was another dream it
was here here's the thing oh the the
PlayStation is
whatever it was like a deep situation
it's so weird because it's just a
professionally lit sorry Written Letter
wow what the heck
um it's a professionally Written Letter
to the CMA like it's literally just his
perspective on everything that's
intelligently ruined like I could I told
them even on tour I was like dude I am
jealous I'll get those pieces it's
amazing it is
I could just write a piece about how
servant I am if they were if they were
going to come at you anyway man you
should have just had king ghost ride it
could have been blasted
a video his cake like The Barbers I
don't got time for them like King B he
got time to really play with them and
really he enjoys he enjoys getting them
in their feelings and it's funny that's
why I do miss him for this stuff chicken
went off on this yes I remember the time
when I when I told everybody they were
frauds for not playing Hades before it
came to Game Pass that that was a little
bit of smoke compared to anything the
king does and by the end of that week I
was nothing no I don't want any more of
this oh they was mad at you with the um
what was it the aunt joint when you said
what was it what was the attic when we
go on Tick Tock we was lit what was it
he said they're gonna have to take them
in water and they can't follow them yeah
they don't like me with the acquisition
sorry continue I heard that I was like
that's a tick tock video
I put it up and I I've never seen a
video get real Tick-Tock traction yeah
but I put that up so I'm sitting there
playing a fortnight game and it's got 10
likes I'm okay 10 likes so I play
fortnite can't come back 30. okay that
seems realistic so I play another game
come back a hundred yeah I'm like okay
what's going on here
like a thousand views so I just refresh
it like I'm not even joking I literally
just do this one time just refresh three
thousand refresh it again
refresh you get seven thousand I'm like
oh so this is what Tick Tock does it's
like
feelings are real
[Music]
um
it's funny to me but it is what it is
anyway that's all I got there you again
for Steve pulling up for the topic you
know what I'm saying you know what I'm
saying chilling chilling and uh we get
these uh what you call we got any uh
yeah we had a couple I think hold on a
second copy these
[Music]
oh
angry hippie five dollars loving Persona
5 on Game Pass I'm about to punk rock
doc all right
then we have cj0 uh uh six pound Super
Chat uh Craig from Ireland here shout
out to the Lord oh I was out there so
it's a year it's not past Euros uh wait
wait hold on that's my man wait did you
say Craig for ballet correct for miles
I was good out there you know I had
checked in you know what I'm saying
Craig really lift for me on double and
that's the whole reasons
that's what's up man you already know
you see what 10 dogs is doing oh yeah
it's amazing he's back and forth they're
coming at him so hardcore about Persona
right now he said I'm gonna buy myself a
Persona 5r shirt to wear at E3 real
quick shout out to Craig yo I'ma tell
you right now y'all ain't had Guinness
until you go to Ireland y'all yeah of
course yeah this is official Jameson is
official I learned a lot I learned when
you drink the drink you got to stop
between the harp and the dick Craig is a
fisherman I'm good every time I go out
the island I'm good I'm hollering my
meds right there continue on one day
yeah I get really loud for that he's a
hawk I got a vocalize a little bit of
annoyance with Jason schrey or something
what happened now so I'm sitting here
during the podcast I'm like yo because I
haven't like failed because when he says
something probably it's a video so so I
see it pop up I'm like yo Jason fry says
something we about to break the internet
we live right now
he's talking about Tom Brady I'm like
come on
baby you talk about games make another
Twitter for for sports nonsense but you
don't need you don't need a cross stream
though
yeah I mean you're into football
you know what he could be in the
football it's not on my time
moving on super chess please uh we got
uh NC ghost of low road two dollar super
chat if that bag is right I'll say bring
back the walk man
I don't know about that you take a big
bag
I ain't trying to have it he go you
drive it and it skips eight nine times
nine nah you know maybe the iPod you
know where's my iPod no akw I tried
brother I got caught up with work man
the man people hit me up when I was out
there but yeah next time I will be back
I will be back continue and then we have
Cassandra M10 Super Chat CMAs forgot
Activision wanted to sell if the deal is
blocked who's buying them 10 cent is
Sony lining up for all the exclusives
and what what about employees suffering
under Bobby cotec that that is yeah
obviously funny I don't think that's
stuff that's being talked about you
can't really be like yeah well you know
we're buying them so we could get rid of
this guy I don't really think you can
say that you know what the funny thing
too is I wonder if like this happens or
like tencent or Sony I tries to buy them
I wonder if the CMA you know because
they because at that point you know you
know Microsoft man you do what Sony did
pull that back pull that bag back
[Music]
oh
what else we got that is it we're caught
up I think once I must make sure I'm not
lying to y'all
nope we're good we're good to go I mean
this is the last one and this I believe
was King's topic we gotta talk about it
man you want to talk about the Xbox
Mobile store like going on in this
Microsoft Tom Warren from The Verge he
said Microsoft is building an Xbox
Mobile gaming store to take on Apple and
Google Microsoft Activision Blizzard is
key to the company's Mobile gaming
efforts Microsoft is quietly building a
mobile Xbox store that rely on
Activision and King games so yeah it
looks like they are preparing to start
this next Generation store and this was
quietly revealed during the UK
competition and Market Authority
situation I'll jump in just to give some
additional contacts on
yeah as far as you know the thing that
people have to realize too is that we
all know Call of Duty is like the the
huge part of the deal we understand the
significance and the exclusivity we're
not going to minimize that but I am glad
King brought this up because I think
what is going under the radar is the
king aspect of the deal right and them
really trying to get into the space and
surprisingly
this doesn't see what the CMA is
concerned about as much as much and and
this you know when you look at you know
what they have there and shout out to
Time Warner who said um you know the CMA
has barely discussed the potential for
Microsoft's entrance into Mobile gaming
as part of its investigation and is
instead largely focusing on Console
gaming which Microsoft argues is an
increasingly smaller part of the overall
market and then we talked about we see
how like um steam deck and Xbox uh the
cloud I've gotten closer we've seen how
um epic and Microsoft have played Banks
now with fortnite we've seen the
exponential growth I forgot what the
percentage was it was like 100 over 100
something percent of fortnite players
playing on cloud and stuff like that
it's like 1800 or something like thank
you thank you thank you for the
correction bro like it's it's insane and
um yeah it's interesting to see you know
again this development in the space so I
wanted to bring King's topic into the
realm stop the Lord Steve first you know
what are your thoughts about Xbox Mobile
store and them really trying to put a
stake in this aspect of Gaming
my first thought is I cannot believe
that Microsoft's not pushing more on
this point with the CMA because we all
know that every regulator in the western
world hates apple and every regulator in
the western world hates Google and they
want to use the law to to slow them down
or to make them break things up but the
law isn't on their side in that I cannot
believe that Microsoft's not going and
saying like hey we can do what you can
we can challenge these app stores we can
challenge the IOS app store we can
challenge the Google app store it'll
take us some time but if we got these
assets with us that's going to be our
way in
um
that's kind of my first thought my other
thought is I think that like
I think that Microsoft moving more
toward the cloud future both with you
know King kind of being like the native
mobile games but then having the
potential to have you know straight up
like everything that I can play on my
Xbox or on my PC being able to play it
on my phone just like I'm like with like
low latency and all that sort of stuff
that's a future that I want to be a part
of um not that I get out of my house too
much but other than that
um but I think that's a future that I
want to be a part of so I'm looking
forward to seeing what how this kind of
materializes and I hope that uh hope
that they're able to uh to make this
happen in a real good way yeah no doubt
no doubt definitely a big part of the
deal not getting talked about a lot Lord
flame what is your feeling on Xbox
entering the Mobile Store Market
all right really don't got much to say
on it like this is actually like
whenever looked at the title I was like
I did not hear about this I didn't do
any proper research so I guess as part
of it like going with what Steve said
like being able to like uh
go up against like uh Apple and Google
and all that kind of stuff it's kind of
like that could actually be a really
good talking point but then it could
also be like
oh no they they actually can because
what was it uh wasn't Google or I think
it's like either Apple or Google that
was saying that
um Microsoft can't have like the game
streaming app or something like that
because yeah yeah because the micro
transactions all that kind of stuff and
they want that piece of the piece they
have to go through browser for those
phones so it's like they could
definitely take that angle with it and
I'm actually shocked that they haven't
done that yet but then again the CMA is
making this more about
the console space and I know Xbox does
want to get exclusivity on this kind of
stuff because they're dropping 70
billion freaking dollars they got to get
something out of this so
they could probably go with both points
at one point but at the same time if
they focus on the mobile angle they'll
they'll go right back to the console
angle anyway is just kind of like
I don't know it's
it's kind of weird I'm not too not too
worse on this no I feel the honesty on
that transparency or not yeah it's very
interesting you know that it's multiple
components of this deal right it's so
much to it it's Activision Blizzard the
studios the mobile the king aspect Cloud
it's so much gorgeous Call of Duty
game it's all that matters just one just
one stagnant freaking shooter and just
to see like um you know the whole thing
with the the Xbox mobile game store and
stuff like that it's it's really
interesting to me but uh Lord addict
what is your feeling on this game store
you're the big com mobile gamer let's go
oh
I think that's cute is what you do it's
just like sitting that right what you do
he was getting that what was it um you
had what's going on your phone as that's
false mobile gamer
that that was
a game now he was Hardcore the whole
thing man I was your mobile game
I told you about the uh first off it
wasn't available at all so we're gonna
we're gonna cut that off right now I
mean I guess it's I guess it's the same
thing it's like this uh or the last
topic we talked about the the the CMA
thing man like look like Xbox I'm
available
I I'm there man you know you you you
want it to be covered like crazy
for the price oh on me yeah man look I
I'm trying I'm trying to cash out hey
let's go I mean look this is clearly
where Microsoft's always wanted to go
yeah uh they they want to be everywhere
it is what it is
done
you know there's actually games on
Netflix
they want to be everywhere they want to
be on your phone on your tablet on your
Xbox on your PC they they want to be an
extension on your Google where you get
to bring something up I you know I have
been working on a video that you know
focuses a little bit on streaming so
it's just like you know
if you like it don't like it like here's
the things Microsoft isn't demanding you
do it they're like look we're trying to
give you options shut up like I I don't
never find an issue with options like if
you want my games mobile do that if you
want to play your games on you know the
Windows PC store do that if you want to
play your games on Xbox do that like
there's no there's no downsides to death
Twitter set us to death the game and the
Xbox Microsoft this is this they trying
to fight this they got it I think
they're just trying to they're trying to
extend their reach to make more money
it's not necessarily it'd be different
now I I I will have one I have one
negative notation with this as long as
it's not this PC nonsense there's
exclusive games on PC but not all packed
no it's just like look like you kill one
part two
you know and it's not that it's I don't
want a scenario where they're making
exclusive games on some platforms but
not others I feel you want that parody
okay
if you're gonna sit there and speak
be where everyone could play it be about
that light okay let me ask you this
though it's a good question good point I
like where you're going what about
because Call of Duty mobile I was like
it's moving out here from my
understanding right I don't play this
game but I heard it's like crazy so like
you even have a problem with that in the
sense that it's a different
excuse not the one-to-one game of course
I guess maybe part of me is like mobile
might be a little bit different because
that's going to be a different audience
but it's just like something like gears
pop like he was making fun of that could
have easily have been on Xbox on PC like
I think it was on PC it was an app on PC
wasn't it that you could have played on
PC okay it's just like look like
my thing with Microsoft is like you
can't
play favorites and I feel like sometimes
you know Xbox has that had an exclusive
since like 2015 or 16 or some crazy
stuff like that Halo has been the like
Halo is like one of the only exclusives
on on the Xbox now Halo uh five and it's
just like you can't have that energy
that you want everything to be on PC but
you want PC games to be only on PC not
Xbox
okay well that's that's my fears they'll
start making stuff only for most oh so
you want so you scared of like the hot
mobile game that don't come in Xbox
it's just like I just want it to be
symmetry everything works on everything
like don't don't start this we're gonna
give you this game and then you know
kind of like they're doing a PC because
I I feel like at that point
you're making the console Gamers feel
like second class citizens everyone gets
something but that console people that
that's my only thing no doubt fear I
mean we still have to we still have to
pay for Xbox Live you know for sure for
sure for sure yeah we we didn't get
Gears tactics when it came out PC got it
exclusively we didn't get it you know uh
Age of Empires PC got that exclusively
so it's just like you know it's a shame
it's like you know I if if they Branch
out in a more areas be better about them
making sure everything comes out at the
same time I think that's a valid point
they don't have to go to play sessions
I'm gonna make that oh my god
let's get PlayStation you know what I
just said they do a mobile with
relaxation you know what PlayStation you
know what Microsoft you can even release
that on the switch it's just thank you
skip that you can skip the PlayStation
you're a messy stop anyway I don't mind
if Starfield has a steam version that's
on the switch your message don't let it
be on Playstation I got I got this I got
to be entertained that day
you know what man
that's a different story yeah he about
to go off on that anyway moving on I've
moved on what's up man this mobile store
what are your thoughts on Xbox venturing
into the space
I mean this is always the plan for
Microsoft my PayPal is in the promises
clearly trying to get bought off here
continue I don't care but but if you're
gonna drop that bag for me to review the
game
for a little price you can make me cash
I didn't care about the Oculus the
opinions
do not reflect
the entirety of Martha gaming.net and I
lost podcast LLC get that disclaimer up
at the beginning let's put that up every
episode yes
anyway continue so
yeah I mean this is always the plan man
when you look at you when you look at
how the amount of variety they have to
put into Game Pass to make it what it's
become right
and where they want it to go you need
you always needed this you always act
and this I said this like a couple years
ago now where it was like don't be
surprised you start seeing mobile games
like pure mobile games mobile games are
definitely industry nah
and I this was before Activision
Blizzard right this was hey if you
wanted to be everywhere and you're
talking about phones and the cloud and
stuff as as the platforms you want to is
as the way you want to have Game Pass
proliferation
and and B is widespread as and
ubiquitous as you want it to be phones
was always the the play so the fact that
they're now looking into putting very
phone-centric sort of products into and
I think it's not its own they call its
own storefront and I guess I definitely
see it but at the same time I do feel
it's a part of game pass because to me
it's a trojan horse right if you want
people that aren't core Gamers to care
about game pass on a phone give them the
phone stuff and then you chosen horse
the regular stuff and see if they if
they latch on to it that's how you
really want to do it because honestly
even in its current state if I'm just a
pure phone gamer I'm a casual game I
don't play consoles I don't play on PC
if I would play something on phone it's
going to be very phone Centric I don't
see the motivation for me to go grab
Game Pass for my phone right but if your
trojan horse that stuff in with the
stuff they want to play the Candy Crush
and and the and the Cod mobile and
whatever else don't forget about the IOP
bags
that's the only way he's gonna play
these mobile games yeah that's the only
way to go plays mobile games so you want
me to play some candy crush I'm gonna
need some candy on my front door pause
move it on and so that to me again this
is always this is just working towards
their master plan
um and they they're doing it right so
to Steve's point and he made
um
Microsoft is also looking to create a
space that differentiates it from the
Play Store and the Apple Store in a way
that makes it look more appealing
obviously to to Regulators where there
are certain practices on those stores
that are not very uh developer friendly
consumer friendly
um this is Microsoft's opportunity to be
like hey
um you wanted to do in-app purchases
right in your own app go ahead do that
go ahead do that yeah we got you don't
worry about it we'll eat that this is
kind of not to cut you but this is kind
of the whole epic what is it the case
and this is what Tim Sweeney is this is
what they try to say they want to make
it or better for developers on that
point so the thing is this is an
opportunity for them to break into that
space in a very real way by offering by
by literally just saying okay you do
this negatively we're going to do the
opposite you do this negative we're
gonna do the opposite and to Steve's
point
it's so fun and I mentioned something
similar uh I think last week of the week
before where I was like the Call of Duty
argument is is the sort of the stupidest
Baseline argument because the Microsoft
is going for so something much bigger
and you're ignoring that completely
technically for the banana
yeah it's like you know when I'll show
you with my hand but my other hand is
doing something and and it just really
feels like this is the big play like
this is the big play and when the gamers
don't care the hardcore game is okay bro
but this is what the money men think
about continue exactly the the money men
are thinking about oh wow if we get
candy crush or whatever and other
third-party support in this in this
service that's in addition to Game Pass
and all of a sudden we're offering
better Revenue cuts and people and
allowing these these games to have their
own in-app purchases and not taking a
cut from that and just allowing them to
live there and giving them a a a
legitimate alternative to going to to
the Play Store in the App Store where
quite frankly it's very easy for your
game to get lost right yeah and
Microsoft has already sort of figured
out a way to have a lot of different
games coexist and then bring to the
Forefront the newest stuff and the most
they're not perfect but they've gotten
much better about bringing all that
stuff to the Forefront in a way that
these these storefronts don't do at all
they have an opportunity there imagine
imagine considerably storefronts man we
gotta hurry up I'm hungry I need to go
to the store to get some food
all of a sudden if we got to give them
five hours bro
out continue so the fact of the matter
is that this was always the play
um it's crazy it's kind of crazy to see
it happening and to them really hey we
say we're going to do this we're doing
it and and the potential for what it
could mean if they do it right and then
and they really do look at the
deficiencies of these other stores and
really make it a super friendly place
for devs to to to work with and and turn
and monetize their games it's gonna be
very very interesting and again you want
to talk about a monopoly in something
you're looking at the wrong place
oh God don't mean a damn thing yeah yeah
listen man it's funny because I always
laugh but can can Sony really speak all
monopolies in a market they're not
really in that much so no but at least
they've indicated that they want to go
to that market right okay
anything you know I'm trying to go into
the into the I'm trying to go in you
know when Fox is trying to by when
Disney's trying to buy a bunch of the
wall I'm trying to go on what they are
in that market you get what I'm saying
that's the first time Bill Herman been
public though public like yo we're
looking to expand and the fact that they
don't look at the council Market as
sufficient just because they probably
have like low-key in the back they Louis
looking to expand and they're talking to
say hey look man we tried to get in the
mobile market but you let them get Call
of Duty we can't do it but this is the
thing though the argument should be the
bigger picture but like look what
everything they're trying to do is going
to put us out of business say that or
whatever the game baby it's going what
is the term that they use of foreclosed
on it they're gonna foreclose on us or
whatever I think they're you know they
would have a lot more of a of a stance
to argue on that if they actually had
like some of the market in that no like
it's hard all they have to say is we
can't do what they do that's all they
have to say we can't do it look what
they're doing we can't even hope to
follow in their footsteps how are we
going to compete
get that but I I just feel like it would
be hard for a company that that that's
not in that industry just to come out
and say well we're considering it but
you know Microsoft's already trying to
buy stuff so how are we really going to
compete in an industry we're not in the
funny thing is they're not even that
Sony's argument is not even really not
even able like they they have really not
well I think that's the I think that's
the reason they don't attack it is
because they don't have enough market
share to say that it would not be
competition
because you can't you don't have numbers
to go to the CMA and say look we're
doing this now and if they did that we
could do this then so I I think it would
be hard to really have an argument
saying they can't compete when they
ain't they're not even competing yet so
I don't know right but the argument that
they couldn't even hope to compete
is is the argument right that makes you
look as weak as you possibly can look
and you want to look weak in the
situation because you want to make a
point so this is the thing like them
having a a a sort of uh a horse in the
race kind of doesn't matter which is why
it's weird to me they don't talk about
it because this is stuff that they no
way in hell they can follow the same
with Microsoft Microsoft is putting so
much money into this there's no way they
could do that and if Microsoft has its
way and everything that they hope
happens does happen the reach of Game
Pass and the the different types of
Gamers The Game Pass reaches
is going to be something that Sony does
not want to see and that's what I'm glad
you said that because to me that's what
the real fight is the real fight is one
business model versus another
businessman and one business model is
retail the single player experience
these these rich amazing games no
disrespect right we they definitely make
high quality games and the way that
model has worked for them up until this
point
the other model with Subscription
Service you know play Anywhere entry
point anywhere is a direct threat to the
way they've been doing business so to me
that's really what the Crux of this
because if the gaming industry goes that
direction mobile PC everywhere
subscription
somebody ain't prepared to really go
there
so the fight to do what you have to do
to keep things status quo I get it I
legit get it because at the end of the
day if the industry does shift that way
and for the people who say like oh
why why does people want something real
quick go for it go for it I actually
feel like taking the subscription model
hurts the case even more because then it
goes out of the the console market and
it's in the third party Market because
then you can't argue that that much
because ubisoft's got one EA's got one
so it's harder to argue a subscription
base because now they've took themselves
out of the console section and they're
fighting on third parties well there's
definitely competition there so it's
harder to fight that yeah I think it's
just at that point it's is there
competition there or sold he can't
compete there hello and they shouldn't
care if Sony can't compete there they
should compare if Microsoft buying that
will make it to where a subscription
rate can't be caught because at that
point Activision don't really got a
subscription so that's not gonna hurt
them all acma is to make sure that
consumers get the best benefit their job
is to protect the consumer the consumer
it gets the best benefit and that
competition is preserved correct
correctly absolutely absolutely and and
that's what I'm saying man you know Sony
pass it out checks I'm there relax watch
it relax yourself and and I think this
is a philosophical battle happening
right now before I here's the thing that
people got to understand and I know my
OG hardcores don't like to hear this
but you got to look at the trends
everything for the most part that is
popping
is now either going subscription service
free to play
and if they're not doing the 70 they're
saying free but you're getting the micro
transactions and you're getting this
other stuff on the back end right
the reality is let's be real
as much as we love these amazing single
player games and things of that nature
that I love I'm hashtag just one I love
those games
is that once you get that initial sale
what else can you get on the back end
right what else can you do to mind
that's why we see all these tricks with
the loot boxes and all this other stuff
because companies are trying to figure
out ways to get this money right and I
just think that
if the shift goes the way it is because
here's the deal these kids they're not
buying the consoles like they on their
phones they're doing these other things
right and if the industry trends that
way right eventually you got to prepare
yourself you don't want to be a dinosaur
completely uncapable of being able to
shift and adapt if it goes that way now
of course there's always going to be a
place for the single play game of course
there's always going to be plays for
these other games but this is where the
industry is training you just seen
OverWatch change they join you know what
I mean they're free to play and for
people who are saying look at the
engagement numbers people saying this is
the definition look at the revenue
that's being made fortnite literally
changed the industry a single title and
forced cross play so we can sit here and
fight yo I don't want this this is that
that's where it's going you could choose
to get out of game and if you like
because you don't like it I get that you
can argue if it's good or bad for a game
it's
exactly so you could be the old man
I hate this it reminds me of hip-hop
it's like I can sit here
I can sit here again and say Nas and
rock him and all the OG dudes is the
best rappers in lyrical Miracle but if
the industry is going little baby the
industry is going whoever the hot new
rapper is the kids are going to win
there's more of them than there are of
you that's what people gotta let their
emotionality out of gaming and look at
Trends and that's what a lot of these
businesses and corporations do they look
at they got the engagement numbers they
seeing if they are mobile they seeing
where they at so the people that's
talking on Twitter y'all not the
majority y'all are Echo chamber fam and
you could be evaporated easily so just
pay attention to where things is going
to get caught out continue the majority
I don't know what you're talking about
it
exactly the problem that somebody finds
itself facing right now is because they
succeeded so much over the last decade
Plus in this old model that they were
able to rest on their Laurels for a bit
and they rested on their Laurels a bit
too long and as Xbox was kind of you
know flattering last generation Phil
Spencer had to convince Microsoft that
there was a path forward and that path
forward Was preparing for a future that
Sony is not quite ready for yeah and so
Sony right now they're just trying to
they're trying to slow things down so
that when this future comes that they're
getting ready for and they're gonna be
ready for it they're going to succeed
because they're a fantastic that's why
you can't okay I'm sorry I was gonna say
that's why you can't say Phil isn't one
of the best leaders in gaming industry
because he literally went into a room to
say look not only do I don't think you
should sell this brand uh here's why I
think we should keep it and I'm gonna
need like 70 billion to do it and that's
that's the genius of feeling and again
it's about adaptability right you have
to be ready to shift if the industry go
goes in an interaction and if you're too
late bro you could be evaporated I've
seen it I'm sorry so I'm just about to
get it no no I just I would have loved
to have been in the room when Sean Laden
and Jim Ryan first heard about Game Pass
I would have loved to have seen that
reaction
because it is that oh no we're late
oh no
we have to Pivot I I can tell you right
now that they that they they're
concerned because they restructured
PlayStation Now for a reason it wasn't
because they if they weren't concerned
about the future they would have just
got rid of it and again they
restructured it for a reason and Native
first place team so to speak right so
why is the first place team mimicking
the subscription Services of quote
unquote the last one because they the
last question they do see yo if the
industry shifts this way we gotta deal
PS now this is not profitable let's
combine this let's do this with
PlayStation Plus let's make this service
the most attractive let's go they're
making a and that was my argument
against King because King doesn't
believe there's going to be a place
right
I feel so too my feeling is the reason
why Sony to me is still going to be okay
and overall for the most part is unlike
the PS3 they are showing adaptability
even though they may not be first like
how Microsoft is and well prepared with
the Azure in the back mode they're like
wait a minute no no we're gonna do we
gonna have some subscriptions ourselves
we're gonna do a service that's going to
be compatible
begrudging but they do it and they're
like yo about yourself and you know what
we got these lenses or whatever whatever
you got that Azure we're gonna change
our backboard you don't partner with
them and adapt if you are not ready if
you're not thinking that it could go
that way that's what I'm saying so
people are not listening to Twitter
and emotionality they're looking at
business and Common Sense
the only argument you could probably
give to to a good degree is Sony has the
ability to hit that switch but do they
have the ability to keep up with the
content that is an argument but oh yeah
but that that's the real argument right
it's like it is that that whole thing
like take them in the deep water and
drown them because they could
technically do
what you're doing just not to the extent
that Microsoft is doing it and they
never will be able to they just never
will be able to the thing is too soft
for me to look at it that's why they're
trying to stop this activity to slow it
down I mean it's going to make the guns
bigger look bungee the bungee
acquisition 10 loud service games it's
happening right before you uh they
understand it yo we gotta have these
joints on our pocket in case it goes
there and if we buy itself enough time
we'll be ready for this transition and
stuff like that but yeah it's it's an
interesting thing to watch as far as the
trends but that's all I got unless
anything anybody else got anything else
on this be good we good all right one
second real quick I do feel like one of
the reasons Sony's trying to stop this
is it's it's money reasons too but it's
just like look like right now they
they're coming up the RPG Microsoft got
that RPGs we let them get that Call of
Duty they're gonna have a ray gun like
like can we really fight no we could put
up a wall to stop to the RPG but that
ray gun I don't know well you said let's
let's stop them from getting the ray gun
let's do what we can and that money that
they get on that back end from Call of
Duty being
you know and that's really all it is
that that is a whole lot of money for
doing a lot of money just to have it on
your platform I get it listen that's
what I said so he's going to do what's
best for their shareholders and fight to
the end I get it I respect it it's going
to be up to the CMA to see how this
thing plays out but yeah that's what I
got just to add like the reluctance on
Sundays into like adapt for well you
know are adapting slowly but they're
still summer long dance I think there
was like a article that came out that
they did not want to do any like uh any
kind of like day one service or sorry
like any day one games in their service
and I don't think that article was even
meaning towards their first party
because I I could believe it that's
understandable like obviously there's
been a lot more money into their games
we can kind of see that but
I think it was like I don't know who
said I think it's like Shuhei in that
article like he literally said something
to the effect of like we want to have
PlayStation Plus as a service that can
be used to discover sorry to ReDiscover
titles right so that brings life to
older games yeah yeah and it's just like
you just really stray though so what was
that so it's kind of and they did like
Shadow words or like obviously smaller
titles but it's like there's still some
reluctance there I would really love to
see them just do more stuff like Xbox
does yeah as a Persona 5 gunfire reborn
that might even get freaking Sonic who
knows but it's like
it's just a little more aggressive on
that even if it's not going to break
your bank it's really nice I think they
will be I think they will be they won't
be with their first party stuff
obviously because they they've already
said that they have they have sort of
the game plan for that right they want
to release the game on on Console maybe
a year minimum a year later it comes to
PC right and they just extend the
conversation around the game and then
and and for them maybe a couple years
after that then it comes to the service
or whatever you know and and that's
that's how they view the lifetime the
you know the sort of the the life cycle
of each of their first party stuff
second party and and then the third
party stuff I think they will I think
they will start dropping more bags for
certain things I I think I would not be
surprised um you know I the only one
that really surprised me this past year
was sifu I didn't really see how Seafood
wasn't in PS plus
um when straight was but again Seafood
did well on its own and I've said it
before I I feel like this day and age
like the day of live service exclusive
if Kane is kind of productive now and I
and I'm gonna I think that not only
we'll see live service day and day you
know I wouldn't be surprised if you
start to see it you know multi-platform
with PC as well you know not this just
oh it's going to be locked only in the
PlayStation yeah you know and then the
bungee stuff the bungee stuff you can
expect to be there be a fight to put
that on Xbox right
and I think there's an argument you know
because we've seen
throughout gaming history where Studios
start making
really good money off games as a service
and they start abandoning the structure
that they were built on yeah especially
I'm sure I'm sure a lot of PlayStation
people are nervous because if a couple
of these games as a service takes off
they might start focusing more on these
games as a service to start start
pulling back a little bit on the single
player stuff I will say this too and I
don't want to like scan people up but I
do feel that if let's say for example
factions right that's one of the ones
that that's waiting to come come for
them I do feel like if a lot of these
joints pop if the industry is going that
way right and I know it's scary people
don't want to hear this talk but if the
industry is going that way and let's
just say you know because I've heard
things internally for games that I don't
care about that a live service or
whatever and you see how much money they
make and then they'll be like oh God but
because of that this help fund all these
others this one yeah they really make
that money and that them single player
games a child or whatever the child
raving about we wouldn't have had the
bread but based on sad titles you know I
mean that that's the thing you got to
look at and you got to look at the
overall benefit for gaming so if let's
say the game that you love right you're
like yo that's that Banger that's that
single player that's just one energy
that's fire I want these games and their
games only but the residuals come back
and you in the red
or you just barely broke even right I'll
give you an example go ahead talk it um
without
the microtransactions that they I think
it's um EA makes off of all the their
sports stuff you never would have seen
it takes two and one game of the year
because that's literally what they
funded that game talk to these devs it's
stuff that for Survivor it's stuff that
blew me away and I was like really like
these that gave me that much money that
stuff that I don't like made that much
and it's just like yeah like this kept
things the lights on and then it allowed
us to do that thing that you like and
I'm like wow okay it's it's interesting
if you if you take what Sean Laden said
as he was leaving PlayStation
this is becoming unsustainable games
it's too big games cost way too much
money
if you take that to heart right and you
know that to be true then all of this
makes a hundred percent sense them
having 10 games uh that a service based
game makes all the sense in the works
all they need is one to hit one all they
need is one that's what people gotta
understand facts all they need is one to
hit and they're setting all the stuff
that you love that you think might be
going away I understand addicts point
because it's true I just don't I think
PlayStation obviously
they hold their single player stuff in
high regard right but I don't I just
don't think James Ryan wants to say that
it wants to say the fact that hey we
need to figure out these other revenue
streams in order to continue to put out
games of that ilk and net quality that
you expect from us otherwise they're
going to be shorter they're going to
have shorter death cycles and they're
not going to be as polished as what
you've seen up until they because it
just it's it costs way too much money
I'm not saying that they wouldn't make
single games single player games so you
know couple of these pop off and do
really good they're okay the people
we're not investing anymore into other
Studios I make these to this type of
content like the students we have now
that's all they're doing like we're not
investing outside of that concept so
like the games that you're seeing out
from the studios you see now that's as
far as it goes they're like the rest of
our bags is going on what's actually
bringing in money I mean we already see
the shift though right I mean to your
point people was mad that day's going
too it wasn't no days going too and then
apparently that went over the two was it
last of us remake remake right and
people like yo why we leave Last of Us
remake remake right oh this is you know
and then the mpds came out
and and that's and that's another thing
that we have to look at what they're
doing with their strategy
cross Media stuff cross media movies
like wait a minute you didn't want to
fund you know uh what you would call it
uh
but you're gonna make a show out of it
yeah because if we take all of these
properties and figure out different ways
they can make us money as a prime
example Sonic the Hedgehog Sonic Sonic
games have not been it for a while right
the hope is that Frontiers changes that
I don't know
but at the end of the day Sonic is as
big as it is because the movies did well
and quite frankly the cartoons the
comics all that stuff and the other
merchandising has continued to do well
despite
the place where he was born and not
being think about the audience outside
of gaming that is big yes huge who don't
know who Sonic is and like yo what's
that oh by the way we got this game now
for that character you just learned
about you just learned that you could go
play right now and now you got a whole
new audience that wasn't a console game
and it wasn't anything that's not into
the Eco Center spending money and buying
your product and buying your product The
Witcher look like cyberpunk look outside
talk about it yeah
the industry is going wake up yes wake
up y'all could fight y'all bro this is
the death This Way is going so either go
get out the game or get like kick say
lay down and stay there this is what it
is the market need to get out of the
game or you can ask for a bag like me
ready get ready yeah so that's it end of
the day the Market's gonna always speak
yes and if the market doesn't want
something it'll tell you and if it does
it'll tell you factual though out well
said well said uh you want me to get the
pole while you creep that uh yeah just a
couple now I'll read the Super Test real
quick uh we got Nova 30 M3 two dollar
Super Chat member for six months
building my patio listening to the
Lord's salute shout out to me
Nova's bad funny on Twitter yeah yeah he
salute them we got the rubber knob
member for one year twenty dollar Super
Chat morning Lord you may have already
spoken about this I have a theory what
if Sony's prevention of developers using
features on the Xbox consoles that
aren't on the PS5 is what is actually
holding back little man
No Doubt okay we got slobo backslap
remember for 29 months thank you sir
Warframe is greater than the division
which is greater than first descent
which is greater than outriders which is
doubly greater than Anthem which is
triply greater than Destiny
why is Destiny on your mind sir I agree
with him sorry listen you you would have
de facto Warframe article man so I got
to be nice to you
yeah yeah just a little bit no no no no
yeah
no doubt anyway latest poll going up
with the latest rumors regarding many
developers frustrated with the series as
Hardware requirements how do you feel
Xbox should address the issue he said oh
slovo said that was for you yeah yeah
I'll be hating on Destiny yeah yes sir
listen man you can't you know I'm saying
you can't come oh Paris Unblock Me Oh
damn anyway the choices are a
listen to the devs drop Series S support
at some point in the generation to focus
on series X only titles B educate the
devs multi-config support has existed
for years Xbox 360 devs and point to
devs who've had tremendous success on S
development or see I don't care y'all
need to speak to these third-party devs
who are performing sorcery or these
switch ports shout out to all the people
in the realm who has been rocking out on
IOP yo send King some love he will be
back you know what I'm saying but I'm
glad y'all rock with the other dudes
podcast yeah I appreciate it appreciate
y'all for staying in rocking it was good
to see y'all up in there had a lot of
fun and of course I would be remiss if
we do not celebrate the amazing Riders
of lawyers who gave me not that I am
super proud of the team trying to do
more of this get y'all on get your
voices heard and you're out here killing
the game so let's start with the editor
one of the top new assistant editors in
the game Lord flame where can I find
people find what you got going on sir
yeah well you can find me on Twitter at
flamelognets uh you
man uh these last few weeks just been uh
just do it with the whole move like yeah
bro you've been moving it's been a nice
little adjustment I got chased off by a
bunch of horses after running the
PlayStation
yeah
it's a crazy time um for an opinion
piece
like I said they filled up my cup
anyways
and um if anyone wants to play Warframe
anytime I'm on I'm always up for it I'm
living ignis on Xbox and I'm gonna make
the announcement here because I haven't
written the article yet because I'm a
dunce
um on Warframe we actually do have an
official uh Warframe clan on Xbox games
with the news of crossplay with Warframe
coming you know slowly over time it's
now PC and Xbox can play together they
can't do a lot of other different things
but um in the future eventually
PlayStation switch will be fully cross
play with like nice you know support for
Clans and all that kind of stuff so if
anything wants to hit me up uh just wait
Warframe was developed on switch wow
they didn't hold the generation
it was the series
Cog that's the only one wow that's just
slushery right there no absolutely you
killing it with the Warframe articles
and then the editorial your asset to the
company man love what you doing brother
keep up the good work stay off the
slander I'm gonna watch you
I'm kind of sad I missed King but that's
probably yeah we all Biz King no doubt
and of course our very old Lord Steve
break taking the internet with the uh
open letter to the um CMA and then also
shout out to your tremendous work on
unique article with Kingdom Come
Deliverance that's solves uh one of his
game break he broke the internet for us
you know with um one of his interviews
with Kingdom Come Deliverance some time
ago for for IOP and they could see you
break it again it's been tremendous in
the short time we've been here you've
done tremendous work well articulated
and you get a lot of rave reviews sort
of keep up the tremendous work where can
the fine people find you what do you
have going on yeah yeah you can find me
at Twitter at scg Perry
um I love chatting with folks about
games it's one of my I spend too much
time on that episode uh y'all can follow
me we can chat and just have a good time
and chop it up a little bit you can also
find me on Xbox at uh crossborn423 is my
gamertag I'm gonna pop that up with my
uh my Twitter profile description as
well because it's spelled a little weird
um but I love to play games I'm going to
hop into uh Warhammer 40K dark tide next
month when that pops off
and so if y'all I know I think it's just
going to be on PC at that time but hey
if anybody wants to hop in on that with
me I'd have we'd have a good time
together no doubt man salute you keep up
the Fantastic work scrapping them off
gonna be crazy next month but anyway
it's gonna be a while heavy debate heavy
debate you already know and of course
the man who needs his food and will
expect except any bag from any company
to be bought off paid 10 pieces of
silver Lord addict we're gonna find
people friends
well you know I I just I just ate some
food that uh Microsoft sent me I don't
be doing no no I I
uh iCloud is a fantastic you know xcloud
is great the opinions of Lord addict do
not respect iCloud
you guys hit that like button man yeah
oh you hit that like button we got stuff
of alarm 130 30 people in here get you a
pillow hit that like button yeah
we we good out here man we good out here
oh
oh you need 12 more for me to review
that rabbits game ah let's do it let's
get those get those 12 likes in the
shows
that's my topic go go go go go
hold it down we're going to find people
finding what you got going on Twitter
yeah you could first of all big shout
out to lock that in the building Lord
Stephen Lord Flynn you guys
in a time where all these other websites
uh are very unfolding and you know
obviously nobody gets paid at lognet
it's all passion and love and you guys
do such an amazing job I'm so proud of
where that site has gone from where it
began like dizzy dizzy is smiling down
what's going on
um so you guys keep doing what you're
doing that's amazing work and for me you
know me you know
what I'm gonna do there's no need to say
but hopefully I will get in some uh some
Gotham nights this weekend some
playtails I'll be able to speak a little
bit on that next weekend
we came closer to that God of War I'm
excited for that and that giveaway
coming soon oh yeah get that rag to rock
I will be doing the trolls next week and
unfortunately Saul took forever to do
the outro so we have about 350 now yeah
yeah baby so what do you got to do he
got to do the old Mario Robinson I I
will be uh I will be getting you that
code this afternoon
review coming up Large review addict and
them rabbits let's go back
and so it's been pretty much yourself
that's it I'm done thank you you already
know again salute everybody when I
pulled up in Ireland and showed up shout
out to my big Craig that pulled up that
was lit and um just the whole team and
stuff like that anybody who I didn't get
a chance to link up with I apologize it
was just crazy when I was out there it
was good to be back just by time when my
body clock it's gonna take a little
while to get adjusted send King some
love even though he hates what I send
that same King we miss him but it's good
to see y'all still rocking with the
other Lords you know
Great Glass um some more surprises we
got some shows coming up some things
cooking and um yeah appreciate it's good
to be back and that's pretty much my
pillows yes please
we get 10 pillows before the end of the
uh for the end of the month uh we will
be doing a live show next month sometime
no doubt and again it should support the
the pillow movement gaming support get
you get you get your posture right get
everything right hello
anyway we gotta go we will catch up the
uh everybody enjoy your Sunday
have a great week
[Music]
all right we back we back we back we
forgot to see what Chad we back no we
didn't forget they came in hot they came
in high Choice got it in Just in Time
game of my choice two dollars to attack
great show everyone thank you thank you
thank you thank you sir
all right we go we good all right
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign